hello everyone welcome to the December
2022 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll I wanted to start off I can't
believe it's December this has been a
long year for me I'm sure for you as
well had a book out changed jobs moved
across the country even the move is not
completely done yet we haven't actually
moved into our official house that's
coming in a couple weeks so things are
been very hectic anyway all this year
it's been a very good year for mindscape
I wanted to just share one very
heartwarming story if you remember a
year ago uh last December we had Joshua
Green from Harvard on the podcast who is
a psychologist and philosopher moral
psychologist thinks about how deontology
and consequentialism play out literally
in the brain but he also is one of the
brains behind giving multiplier which is
a way to leverage two different facts
one fact is that certain Charities are
more effective than other others in
changing lives and saving lives and
making people healthy and the other fact
is that we have certain emotional
connections to certain Charities you
know the local cat shelter is going to
be an important one to me so give me
multiplier makes it possible to do both
you can give money and you can give some
to your favorite local specific
Charities and they will also spread some
love to high impact uh Charities that
spend money on whatever the data says is
the most effective way to do it so
giving multiplier when Josh came on the
show uh had a special deal for mindscape
listeners you could go still True by the
way you can go to https
colon slash slash giving multiplier.org
invite slash mindscape and you can
donate and they will extra match so
there's a little bit of extra oomph to
your donations and this was a year ago
and wait for it we got 165
000 in donations from mindscape
listeners to give you multiplier and uh
Josh sent me the list of places that
have been benefiting from this clean air
task force Johns Hopkins Center for
Health security nothing to do with the
fact that I'm a Johns Hopkins they're
just uh Health security is important
thing anyway Helen Keller International
Etc so mindscape listeners have uh
provided enough for over 5 000 deworming
treatments over 3 500 vitamin A
supplements 400 malaria nuts a whole
bunch of of other things so it warms my
heart that uh the mindscape listeners
have been that great also of course in
parallel we have the mindscape big
picture scholarship at bold.org which
we're going to be giving out college
scholarships this year to people
studying these big questions and you
know it it makes me feel good that we're
doing something good when I started this
podcast four years ago now it was an
experiment didn't know whether I was
going to keep doing it didn't know
whether anyone would come on things like
that didn't know whether to build an
audience but it's been great and I'm
just super duper thankful and
appreciative to all of the people out
there who listen uh some of you
contribute on patreon that's uh
something you can do you can go to
patreon.com wait is it patreon.org I
should know I should be better at this
right it's patreon.com
Sean M Carroll and if you contribute
there you can ask questions at the
monthly ask me anything episodes like
this one we have right now but that's a
tiny fraction of the total listenership
that's fine I'm very very happy just if
people listen to it at all talk about
the ideas I've been super happy with the
quality and the and the diversity and
the uh and the sort of amazing
inspiration we get from the guests you
know the people have been very very
generous with their time and it's
completely a hundred percent fulfilled
my hopes of helping me learn about
things that I just didn't seem to have
time to learn about just by reading
books and things like that so now I
forced myself to read the books when
when the guests come on so uh mindscape
listeners have been great and I
appreciate them very much and it's been
a good year been a good four years so
let me remind you again if you're on
patreon you can ask questions I'll
apologize once again I know I always do
this but I didn't get to do nearly all
the questions there were just so many
questions a lot of it's kind of charming
people are asking kind of very technical
questions in areas of physics that are
not my area and I I'm warmed to think
that you can that you think I can answer
those questions but I can't I have
specific knowledge within physics but
there's other things I don't really know
a lot about so if I don't answer your
question about that sorry about that and
the final reminder is that at every year
I take a week or two off over Christmas
over the holidays so there will not be
any episode you know nearest to
Christmas and there will be no ask me
anything episode in early January right
so the next asking anything episode is
going to be in early February we do 11
of these every year and so this is one
of them and with that let's go
[Music]
our first question is from Rue Phillips
who says you Colin Wright and Jerry
Coyne commented on a Twitter thread
regarding the spectrum of sex you appear
to come down to the side that says
science says sex is a spectrum not
talking about gender here coin and write
claim that science says sex is binary
with abnormalities they seem to feel
this distinction is more than just
semantics coin says if sex is a spectrum
and not binary then people of different
genders can somehow feel that they are
in harmony with biological reality but
that's an example of the appeal to
Nature the rights of people of different
genders including transsexual people do
not depend on the developmental biology
of sex or of any observations in nature
about sex dichotomies with this context
can you please elaborate on your views
of how you think we should be talking
about biological sex in public forums
yes I figure I will get this one out of
the way right away for those of you who
saw on Twitter a while back there was a
tweet by Colin Wright that just said
said biological sex is real immutable
and binary and I replied uh with her
quote tweeted rather with a link to a
Scientific American article and I said
actual science would like a word in the
Scientific American article was beyond
xx and x y and it was about all the
different ways that biological sex is
kind of complicated and the first thing
is the actual tweet that I wrote the
wording of it was terrible and I do
apologize for that actual science would
like a word it's snarky it's dismissive
it lowers the tone of the debate and I
try to do better I want to do better
this is sincerely true that I don't
think that people should just be so glib
and snarky and sarcastic on social media
but there's an enormous
sort of push to do that and I am not
immune to that so I should have just
said something like it's more
complicated than that but okay but this
but the actual substance of what I'm
saying I think is 100 correct so I
thought I would take the opportunity to
um
elaborate here because Twitter is a
terrible medium for elaborating on
subtle arguments at all
I mean by the way you know I waded into
this kind of an offhand moment and lots
of people chimed in and not very
productive ways right I mean it's like
opening the sewage spigot when you when
you start writing about these things
there's lots of comments from not from
my followers right but various dark
corners of the internet found this and
linked to it so you got a lot of
comments that you really don't want to
spend a lot of time reading and these
people are very devoted to it right you
know it's not just the comments on that
tweet but then they leave comments on
other tweets calling me brain damaged
and uh you know insane and things like
that and worse kinds of insults then
they look for me on other social media
so you know my Facebook page or my uh
Instagram or whatever I just get
comments with the same kinds of insults
it's not my style I'm not really into
this kind of uh kind of name-calling
invective combat but uh there you go I I
entered into it I my feeling is that
here on mindscape there are are many
listeners who would be interested in my
thought process whichever side you are
on right and I think that there's
valuable reasonable arguments on both
sides and maybe you've already made up
your mind but you're interested in why I
think what I think therefore I'm going
to talk about it so
the idea is the following human
sexuality is complicated it just is
complicated of course we all have we all
know from high school biology that there
are chromosomes XX or XY in general for
what we typically identify as women and
men but there's other combinations there
can be different sort of people can be x
x y and things like that and then it's
not just your genes there's development
there's hormones there's the final
product there's the primary sexual
characteristics there's the secondary
sexual characteristics there are
characteristics of people that are sort
of weekly but nevertheless definitely
correlated with biological sex like how
tall you are or the depth of your voice
or things like that and of course
inevitably there are psychological
sociological cultural political aspects
of sex who you think of yourself as how
you are treated by other people what
bathrooms you can use news okay what
rights you have how you dress there's a
million different aspects to sexuality
that are all complex and absolutely
there there are intersex people who are
even biologically physiologically rather
not completely clearly male or female in
the traditional sense the second podcast
I ever did or maybe third podcast I ever
did was with Alice Drager
the Talk's all about this and so you can
go back to that podcast to hear some of
the science there and okay so that's I
think that basically every reasonable
person recognizes those complications
the question is how to talk about those
complications so I think that there are
issues here that are not purely semantic
but there are absolutely semantic issues
here there are biological issues here
but there are absolutely also
philosophical issues and language issues
here I mean there's the facts that
science tells us is what happens in the
world but then how we conceptualize them
how we divide them up how we label them
how we talk about them is a more
complicated question so just like in a
very different context the question of
free speech uh the thing that I will not
back off on is the is the point of view
that says this is complicated if you
think it's simple you're just not paying
attention or you have some other agenda
of course many people do have another
agenda one way or the other
so in the face of this kind of
complication why would you think that
sex is binary and clearly immutably
binary well you know there's it's not
completely surprising or out of the blue
right to a good approximation most
people many people human beings are
pretty regularly easily classified as
male or female right into one of those
two categories that there are other
possibilities that you know are
complicating the picture but
approximately they exist so as a
scientist as a biologist you might say
well is there something clear and
biologically definite that kind of maps
on to this informal casual human scale
Association of people as either male or
female so you can look into it and you
can do the science and the answer is to
some extent yes there are aspects of
biology that are that really are binary
okay and the one that is most most often
people disagree about what they want to
say but the one that is most often
brought up is the size of your gametes
your gametes your your uh the sexual
um cells the reproductive cells I should
say uh sperm and OVA roughly speaking
right so there is more or less a binary
where some human beings produce OVA big
sessile gametes some human beings
produce sperm Tiny mobile motile uh
gamits and that's more or less a binary
there's not a lot of in between in that
and therefore as a biologist you can say
okay that's what I mean when I say
biological sex I mean that and that's
you know 100 fine as a term of Art in
biology you are very welcome to do that
you've learned something very very good
it does make for a weird dating profile
if you say yeah I'm you know 5 10 28
years old sandy blonde hair small motile
gametes nobody ever says that right why
not what is the point of me bringing
this up well somehow for hundreds and
thousands of years uh human beings have
been able to have this concept of human
sexuality without knowing anything about
the size of their gametes the reason why
is because of course there is not a
unique one-to-one map between the size
of your gametes and the other aspects of
human sexuality and it's a complicated
picture that's why it's okay that's why
we have intersex people and transgender
people and all these things it doesn't
begin and end with the statement about
the size of your gametes so if you want
if you if you want to use that
terminology that's fine you can go ahead
and do that speaking as a biologist
speaking as you know uh someone who is
just talking about certain biological
aspects of human beings but then
you could choose to be clear if really
what you mean is that and then you want
to put up a tweet you could just choose
to be honest and straightforward and say
human beings either have large sessile
gametes or small mobile gametes and
guess what no one would argue with you
it would not be a thing
the reason why people go on and say and
translate that into biological sex is
real immutable and binary in a way that
doesn't make clear that they are
referring to this term of art within the
context of biology is precisely because
they want to claim more than that
because I agree with Jerry Coyne very
very much that the uh I mean this sort
of I agree with the contrapositive of
what he is saying I don't know whether
it's true that people of different
genders want to feel their harmony with
biological reality or not that that I I
don't judge one way or the other but the
claim that the rights of people of
different genders including transsexual
people do not depend on the
developmental biology of sex that I
agree with
so why would people be on the internet
you know shouting about sex being a
binary why would people get invited on
the Tucker Carlson show to talk about
the size of gametes it's not because
Tucker Carlson has an especially
important uh strong interest in Biology
one way or the other it is precisely
because they want to cheat they want to
equivocate between the biological
definition and the human scale
definitions they want to use the
language and deploy it in such a way
that you can say sex is only binary
therefore we should not believe that
trans women are women for example you
know personally I think that I'm less
invested
in these language battles than a lot of
people are I mean invested in them as an
intellectual as a philosopher and
scientist I'm interested in how the
language works and trying to get it
right but on the political level I'm I'm
less convinced that this is a crucially
important thing and this is that both
sides kind of thing there are people who
want to argue sex is only binary and the
reason why they want that linguistic
move to be reified so they can say
therefore you should not be allowed in
this bathroom right they want to make
that leap which is you know
at the level of philosophy or science
whatever completely wrong but they want
to be able to make that they think that
if they can just get the language right
then the moral and cultural implications
will follow and on the other side you
have people who say trans women are
women
and I think that's true I would agree
with that statement but I'm not that
invested in it because I think that the
reason why people care about a model
like that so much is they think if we
can just get that language accepted then
trans women's rights will be respected
and I just don't think that that's
necessarily true I think that the people
who want to discriminate against
transgender people will do so regardless
of what the language says they would be
very very happy to accept a compromise
that says okay trans women are women and
we're gonna discriminate against that
subset of women right they would take
that compromise and likewise I think
that people who want to protect the
rights of trans women would be if I were
them I would say and I am one of them
but I'm one of the people who want to
protect the rights not one of the people
who is actually trans so I don't want to
speak for them but I'd be happy to give
up on the language if I got the rights
that's my personal take on it so I I do
think that that's what needs to be
resisted it here if you wanted to just
say we have a term of Art in biology
that reflects a true binary in the size
of gametes that's fine go ahead say that
but it is very very intentional that
people have other agendas here other
than just getting the biology right and
I think that speaking out against those
agendas calling out the move that is
being made there is perfectly
appropriate
but it's not the only strategy going on
here there's another strategy which is
to say
um okay there are two basically normal
kinds of people right there are people
who are men and people who are women and
the other people have a disease or a
deformity or some kind of deviation from
the norm and so we're not going to count
that it remains even though there are
intersex people and trans people Etc
that's because those people are deformed
somehow and it remains true that really
the essence of things is that there are
either just men or women you know that's
a an old not very
um
valorous move to make in human history
where you say well some people are
normal and other people are deviant and
we're going to Define that deviance as a
disorder this has been done to people
who are black this has been done to
people who are gay this has been done to
people who are left-handed it's a
standard human move to say that people
who I think are kind of icky and not
normal are somehow deformed and diseased
and this is why you see in you know the
medical literature the definition of
what is a disease or a deformity or
whatever changes over time as we try to
sort of get over our biases and actually
get down to the medical reality of it
all and you don't want to throw away the
idea of disease and deformity entirely
those those exist those are useful
Concepts out there in the world but I
certainly don't think that it's right to
just put everyone who is not absolutely
traditionally male or female in the
stereotypical way into that bucket you
know one thing you can do is ask them
ask these people whether they think that
they're suffering from some kind of
deformity uh and I think in a lot of
cases they think that they're fine I
mean there is something called gender
dysphoria right that is that is a
disease that is a condition that it is
better to try to get over where you
think that you are you know your your
self-image is different from your
presentation your body in some way right
a mismatch between biological sex and
gender identity and what that but that
doesn't mean that transgenderism is a
disease trans recognizing that you are
trans is the solution to gender
dysphoria and people are generally much
happier when they can live in a world
which accepts their uh trans identity
and so I think that we should be working
hard to make that the world we actually
live in so um I'm not I'm not at all
convinced by people who want to uh get
over this issue by sort of classifying
certain people as just a disorder
finally there's one other strategy that
that people use which is basically to
count and say well you know so many
people are just ordinary regular normal
it's a very normative kind of language
that is used here right but so many
people are just obviously male or female
that who cares that there are other
people who is a tiny minority that that
doesn't change the idea that I can talk
about sex as being immutable and binary
Etc and that there's a one example that
is used over and over again I don't know
it must be it must come from somewhere
there's not a million people who
separately hit on this but the example
is it's like saying human beings are
bipedal right or human beings have two
legs uh sure there are people who don't
have two legs but nevertheless it's so
true and so very often true that we can
say it anyway I love this example
because it completely proves my point
the point being that uh I I would get it
if you said human beings are bipedal uh
I I would understand if I were a person
who had gone through amputation and
didn't have both legs that I would be
annoyed by this particular formulation
um but still if you're simply and
clearly within some context trying to be
casual and approximate and you know
click and not too careful then you can
say things like that yeah human beings
have two legs I get it
but what if you say human beings
necessarily always and exclusively have
two legs I mean the content of your
statement is the same right human beings
are bipedal and human beings always
necessarily uniquely have two legs you
just added some adjectives there but
your statement has become false because
all those little signaling words are
precisely doing the work of saying I'm
not just trying to be casual right I'm
trying to be very very definitive about
this and then you're wrong because
that's just not true that human beings
uniquely definitively have two legs if
you want to say you know there are men
and there are women just as a if you're
talking about I don't know you're
writing stories and USA is character
male or female and you're not
particularly in tuned to issues of trans
Identity or whatever fine I'm not going
to give you a hard time but if you go
out of your way to like demand that
biological sex is real immutable and
binary you're exactly saying human
beings must only ever have two legs and
that is it and that's just wrong you're
you're specifically going outside the
domain of where you could be taken
seriously there so I don't think I think
that whether or not the percentages are
relevant or not actually depends on the
Precision with which you're trying to
talk and if you want to you know say oh
is your is your child a boy or a girl
that's fine I'm not going to give you
trouble about that but if you say your
child must be a boy or a girl there's no
other choices which one is it then I'm
going to give you trouble because you're
just you know trying to make some
political point that is of course the
point right I mean these people have a
political agenda lots of people have
political agendas on all sides right and
that's what makes it difficult to have
reasonable conversations about these
things so you know I hope that
whether or not you agree with with my
perspective here the people listening
here are at least willing to Think
Through the difficulties of these kinds
of issues like I said I'm not that
devoted I'm not interested I don't care
that much about this particular issue I
care a huge amount about whether we
treat human beings with dignity and
respect including people who are
intersex including people who are trans
I think that in the world we live in we
do not do that right now uh these people
suffer they are you know subject to
depression and suicide and bullying and
it's an embarrassment you know it's
something that as a culture we should be
embarrassed about it's one of the very
clear ways in which we fall short of
giving all human beings equal dignity
right and I don't get it uh I'm not
going to give you points for making a
big deal about the the sex binary if you
don't also make a big deal about the
fact that there's a whole bunch of human
beings that we treat like [ __ ] here in
the world that's what I would think is a
much more important point Henry Jacobs
says the Margaret Levy interview was
dope in a previous AMA I pitched Lottery
voting as an alternative election system
I'd sum up your critique is I get it but
we can't elect Nazis three percent of
the time and I agree here's a modified
version I'll call diet Lottery voting
sample 100 citizens and have them vote
in a plurality election use carrots and
sticks to ensure that sample citizens
cast a vote sadly the system is
non-proportionate but the fringes are
deregularized or sorry are regularized I
think that what Henry means is uh the
three percent to end up in the 100
citizens are not going to have a big
voice
he continues I think a diet Lottery
system could improve the tone of
politics because it would be a waste of
time for a candidate to Rally her base
and get out the vote under the system
this is because the voting population
the random sample will exhibit 100 voter
turnout so getting out the vote is just
not a thing instead the candidate should
spend time talking to open-minded
non-partisans anyway that's the theory
is it convincing
you know I I even though this is against
my um usual response to this kind of
thing I kind of like this idea I don't I
think that it would well there's zero
chance will ever be implemented I think
as a political reality but I I do see
advantages you know it's similar in
spirit to the idea of sortition uh which
I had never heard of but Esther Taylor
introduced me to when we did her podcast
uh a while back about democracy and
sortition is just when you have some
issue that is very hot button like it
was used in Ireland for talking about I
guess birth control and abortion
something like that you randomly collect
a small group of people put them in a
room and ask them to hammer it out and
the act of being randomly selected is
really makes people devoted to the cause
you know it's it's interesting how that
works they take it seriously for the
most part and they come up with a pretty
good compromise so basically what Henry
is suggesting is sortition but for
voting for actually choosing our
Representatives who will do the
day-to-day work of of governing the
country and I like the idea that getting
out the vote becomes less important
that's also achieved of course just by
making voting mandatory like they do in
Australia and some other places the
other thing that this kind of thing
would do would be to change how money
infects politics right I mean getting
out the vote is one thing but there's a
whole way that money distorts everything
in politics because you have to get out
the vote and you have to campaign and
that costs a lot of money and so the
people who give you money get outsized
influence whereas if it's just randomly
selected people every year uh it's
harder to see how spending millions of
dollars to win their affections would
work presumably you could just try to
buy their votes but maybe you could put
some legislation in there or some rules
to prevent that so I don't know I
haven't thought about it very much but I
like the outside the box thinking you
know I think that we have a terrible
system right now and we're kind of
paying the price for having a terrible
system I don't like the plurality voting
aspect of Henry's idea I think we can do
better you know what one thing that
teaching the physics of democracy course
has impressed upon me is is the
difficulty but also the importance of
having a representation system that
takes lots of people's opinions into
account you know the whole problem with
plurality or first past the post-voting
is that the majority wins and that's it
and the minority uh voices just don't
get in there in any way and if you have
a more some kind of more so the typical
example being if there's one candidate
that is loved by a majority but hated by
49 they will win uh whereas someone who
could more or less have been acceptable
to everyone will lose and maybe that's
not the right choice but anyway that's
that's tweaking around the edges I like
the idea of thinking outside the box in
this way I don't know if anyone else has
suggested it but I'll think about it
some more
I'm going to group two questions
together
olflobial says simply what does it mean
to be a naturalist and Leo bahe says
although I call myself a naturalist for
practical purposes I'm unsure how we
could even Define something outside of
the natural world if we were to discover
some other stuff that behaved very
differently from our current
understanding of how the world behaves
there would still have to be some way in
which that stuff would interact with
everyday things like protons electrons
Etc to whatever extent this other stuff
interact with everyday matter we would
simply model those interactions as best
we could with experiment in theory given
that do you think it would ever be
possible even be possible in principle
to discover anything that wouldn't fall
under the category of natural so both of
these questions are this is a classic
question like how would you ever know
whether something was not natural or not
I think that you know naturalists Define
what they do in terms of a distinction
between the natural world the natural
phenomena and non-natural world and
non-natural phenomena and implicitly
although sometimes they don't spell it
out I think that the distinction has to
do with regularity and predictability
and and law based Behavior you know if
you have a harmonic oscillator you know
exactly what it's going to do it's not
making choices that are unpredictable in
some way uh whereas there is some idea
that something Supernatural or whatever
would be a mind or an intelligence or in
some ways not beholden to the laws of
nature to any laws at all in principle
but honestly I don't worry about this
question that much because I think that
this is not a problem for naturalists
this is a problem for non-naturalists I
think the naturalists have a pretty good
idea what they mean there's a world it's
the natural world it obeys rules we can
discover what those rules are by doing
science by proposing hypotheses and
testing them empirically if you want to
say something else then be my guest but
it's your job in that case to specify
exactly what it is what you're saying I
think naturalism is perfectly obvious
the problem here is defining
supernaturalism and that's not really my
job
Paul Hess says if a particle has a 50 50
chance of being spin left or spin right
and then I measure it to be spin left
does that change its overall momentum is
there any sort of conservation that is
no longer true because of this uh it
changes the momentum in the world that
you're in but typically in a way that
you're going to measure this kind of
thing the momentum goes somewhere else
so you have interacted physically when
you measure with some apparatus and that
interaction involves the spin or the
angular momentum of the apparatus as
well and everything is conserved there
is a subtlety there uh I didn't group
them together but there's a subtlety
there when it comes to energy which is a
little bit different than these other
things but it certainly can and probably
is the case that overall momentum or
angular momentum in particular is
conserved in these kinds of interactions
Andrew K says I really enjoyed the
biggest ideas in the universe I think
you clearly covered the encoding of the
curvature side of Einstein's equation
the left-hand side but I'm still unsure
about the stress energy size died
especially the off diagonal Parts how do
we know it covers all possible forms of
energy is there a good resource where I
can learn more about it well you know
there's always
something you can't get into when you
write a book like that there's always
some level of technical detail that it's
hard to cover in this case there is
something called the stress energy
tensor the right hand side of Einstein's
equation and it was invented long ago in
some form or another and then of course
we come to understand it better and
better as time goes on I think that the
best way of thinking about the stress
energy tensor is basically the tiny
variation of the matter action with
respect to changes in the metric
now those words might mean nothing at
all to you and that's why I didn't go
into explaining it but the point is that
mathematically there is a very specific
very well posed definition of the stress
energy tensor it's not just that we take
all forms of energy and throw them in
there okay we know exactly what we mean
by that now having said that there are
still debates there are people who go
back and forth about can you modify what
do you mean by the stress energy tensor
can you improve it in Quantum field
Theory these these debates go back quite
a ways and they're all subtle and
interesting and so forth but I think you
should be confident that the basic
picture is pretty solid as far as a good
resource where you can learn more about
it I don't know I mean obviously if you
want all the technical details I wrote a
textbook in general relativity and the
technical details are all in there space
time and geometry I'm not sure if anyone
covers it at a non-technical level it
might be there is a book by Bernard
schutz I think which tries to do gravity
at the sort of semi-technical level that
I did in the biggest ideas but I'm not
actually familiar with the book I've
never I've seen it on Amazon but I've
never actually leafed through it but
that might be a place where you could
look
Kyle Stevens says in your recent podcast
with Rafael buso you seem to object to
his idea that the cosmodial constant may
not be constant as he believes it would
lead to the boltzmann brain problem
could you explain why you disagree with
this if you disagree at all so look I'm
going to confess I do not remember
exactly what I said in the conversation
with Raphael but more importantly I will
try to tell you true things that I
actually believe
the cosmological constant is there's
three possibilities here
um one is that the cosmological constant
that we observed today is just it once
and for all forever uh the universe will
continue to expand ordinary matter and
radiation will dilute away we will come
close to something like decider space
which is empty space with nothing but a
tiny positive cosmodial constant another
possibility is that
the cosmological constant is temp is
constant at the moment but will undergo
a phase transition sort of a sudden
change to some other number sometime in
the future and the third possibility is
that even though it looks pretty
constant the cosmotional constant is not
quite the answer not quite what the dark
energy is the dark energy is almost
constant but in fact it's somehow slowly
changing it's a kind of dynamical dark
energy
I think that that last option even
though it's extremely popular is also
very very hard to make work because if
you have some thing that is slowly
changing that's a dynamical entity
that's a field and that field can
interact with other things in the
universe and we should have seen those
interactions already and we haven't yet
there are loopholes there uh if you go
back to I did a uh I think a holiday
message podcast about the screwy
Universe some time ago I talk about that
possibility there but I I just don't
think it's a natural solution the
temporary changes
um or rather the sort of temporary
constancy of the cosmological constant
punctuated by phase transition changes
that is possible but also it's hard to
make it work because if those changes if
that phase transition could happen at
all
it might very well have happened already
I mean chances are I would say that it
should have happened already you need to
kind of like really very carefully tune
it so that it will happen in the future
but it hasn't happened yet so I think
both of those uh options are a little
bit dicey and it's just sort of more
natural to stick with the constant
cosmological constant now the boltzmann
brain problem is is a kind of separate
thing there are separate issues there uh
the boltzmann brain problem
has been mentioned as something that
would be a problem for the real world if
we approach to sitter space as I pointed
out in a paper with Kim body and Jason
pollock a while ago that depends on your
opinions about quantum gravity and
Quantum field Theory and curves face
time in fact it is very very natural to
imagine that we do approach to sitter
space but we do not get dynamical
fluctuations into boltzmann brains
that's a technical point about how the
fluctuations work but it depends on
certain assumptions and if the
assumptions go the other way things
would be different so there was
absolutely an idea that one way of
escaping the boltzmann brain problem
would be for the cosmotional constant to
go away before too long Don Page among
other people has suggested this I think
maybe Andre Linde did also
um and in fact that's how I stumbled
across this idea with Jason and Kim
because Kim and I wrote a paper asking
whether or not uh the Higgs boson could
lead to a change in the cosmological
constant that would help us escape from
the waltzmann brain problem and then in
thinking about it more and more we
realize that maybe there's an easier
Escape it just wasn't a problem uh if
you took the quantum field Theory
seriously so I forget exactly what
Raphael said but that's how I see the
situation right now
Bruno tashera says could we get an
explanation of the hierarchy problem I
believe it has something to do with the
predicted mass of the Higgs versus the
actual mass but when we discovered it
did it match the prediction is there a
naive prediction and a more informed
fine-tuned prediction well yeah so when
you when you talk about a prediction for
the Higgs Mass what are you allowed
yourself or allowing yourself to know
ahead of time so when we found the Higgs
boson we already knew a lot about low
energy physics right we know a lot about
the W bosons and the top quarks and how
they interact and things like that and
the Higgs boson even before you directly
detect it feeds into those predictions
so you could sort of indirectly say the
Higgs boson Mass had better be more or
less here and it was more or less there
where we found it but there's also the
attitude you can take well what if I
didn't know about the mass of the W
boson and the mass of the top Quark
because after all those depend on the
Higgs boson so if I just said well in
the world of all possibilities what is
the most likely place for the Higgs
boson Mass to be that's where you get
the hierarchy problem because then it's
a little bit dicey and I kind of don't
like it and I think the hierarchy
problem is less well understood than
people claim it to be
but the general idea is that you can
take things like the mass of the Higgs
boson or maybe arguably be better to
talk about the expectation value of the
Higgs field in empty space the value
that the Higgs field has and you can
calculate
that value as a sum of what you might
think of as the classical value the
value that would exist if there were no
such thing as quantum mechanics and then
Quantum corrections to that classical
value and the reason why this is dicey
is because nature certainly doesn't do
that nature doesn't start with the
classical value and add corrections to
it it just has a value okay but
nevertheless if you do take that
attitude what you find is that even if
you make the classical value very small
the quantum Corrections should be
enormously big if you don't add in new
physics to squelch them somehow the
quantum contribution to the mass of the
Higgs or the expectation value the Higgs
diverge as we say so they grow bigger
and bigger maybe up to the plank scale
or something like that so that's the
hierarchy problem the hierarchy problem
is that our natural expectation for the
magnitude of the Higgs expectation value
or mass is way bigger than the actual
empirical value that we find it at it's
very very very much like the
cosmological constant problem
with one big important difference the
cosmological constant problem says all
of the same things classical Value Plus
Quantum Corrections Quantum Corrections
diverge and they're big but the actual
number is small the really big
difference is in the case of the
hierarchy problem there was at least the
possibility
that we would discover new physics at
the right energy scale to explain the
hierarchy problem whether it was
supersymmetry or extra dimensions of
space or strong Dynamics or whatever you
want it to be whereas with the
cosmological constant the energy scale
associated with the cosmotional constant
is so incredibly low like way less than
electron volt that there's no room for
new physics there we would have seen any
physics that is that is really relevant
there and so that was always thought to
be more of a puzzle now we've looked now
in the Large Hadron Collider to try to
find new particles that might be
relevant for the hierarchy problem and
we have not found them so maybe going
forward they will be thought of as
similar kinds of problems
all right I'm going to group two
questions together one is from Jay
Peters who said a deep tension within
your views you're open to the idea that
time and space will turn out not to be
aspects of the universe when described
at the most fundamental level yet you
also claim to be alone time 76ers fan
meaning that you trust the process where
a process is a series of events that
unfold in time perhaps you should jump
onto the Golden State Warriors Dynasty
train and then Keith says do you have a
second team that you root for after all
the Golden State Warriors or originally
the Philadelphia Warriors and had Wilt
Chamberlain so Jay I'm sorry that is not
attention within My Views because for
two reasons number one
I'm actually much less definitive about
time not being fundamental than I am
about space I think space is not
fundamental almost certainly I think
that time is a much dicier proposition
and we just don't know I'm pretty open
maybe it's emergent maybe it's just
fundamental I'm I'm not decided about
that yet but even if it is emergent I'm
still allowed to trust the process I
trust an emerging process that makes
perfect sense so I have no
incompatibilities inside my soul as far
as that one is concerned as far as uh
rooting for the Golden State Warriors
you know I did root for the Golden State
Warriors back in the day so for two
reasons number one as you say Keith uh
they used to be the Philadelphia
Warriors they were will Chamberlain's
first team back in the early 60s before
they moved to San Francisco and the
Syracuse Nationals moved to Philadelphia
to become the 76ers but also because
some years ago uh the Golden State
Warriors were Plucky underdogs and they
went of their last pieces of the puzzle
for them was signing Andre Iguodala who
had started his NBA career with the
76ers and was always a great player
someone who was very easy to root for
and he played a big role in those
Championship Golden State Warrior teams
so before they had even come close to
winning a championship I was rooting for
them because they were Plucky underdogs
and had one of my favorite players on
there Steph Curry who's always a lot of
fun now it's a lot less fun to root for
them as your second team I mean they're
doing too well right like what's the
what's the excitement there my heart is
always with the 76ers even though this
year it's been let us generously say an
up and down year so far I'm hoping that
they will find their groove get over the
injuries before too long
Mike Briggs asks a priority question in
the form of a poem the poem is entitled
The spherical cow and it says I never
assumed a spherical cow I hope to never
do that but I can tell you here and now
I'd rather do than boo that with many
thanks to gullet Burgess who wrote a
similar piece of dog roll a while back
and Mike says surely this is not an
original thought but I haven't heard it
on an AMA so let's go uh I perceive no
questions in here so I'm not sure
exactly how to respond to it I think the
point of Mike's priority question was
just to get me to read the poem out loud
now I have done that so I think that my
job here is done
Paul Conte says I do realize that you
don't particularly like questions of the
is it possible variety however do you
think it likely given the expansion of
the universe and the structure of the
cosmic web that there may be entire
galaxies or clusters of galaxies that
are made exclusively of anti-matter so I
think I've actually answered a question
like this before but I wanted to answer
it because Paul you're so close to doing
what I'm what I hope people do so you're
right I do not like questions of the is
it possible variety but then you didn't
ask a question like that what you asked
was do you think it's likely now that's
a much better question to ask so just
forget about asking is it possible ask
about the likelihood ask you know how
reasonable certain things are not
whether they're possible or not that's
not the point I think that people make a
mistake like if something's possible
then there's at least a 10 chance that
it's true and I want to get over that
particular option in the case of
anti-matter galaxies there's way way way
less likelihood than 10 percent because
as you know when anti-matter comes into
contact with or Airy matter it
annihilates and gives off an enormous
amount of high energy radiation now you
might say these galaxies are very far
away we're not in contact with them
that's less true than you might think
their high energy cosmic rays going back
and forth between galaxies that actually
you can calculate would be pretty
visible if certain galaxies were
spitting out high energy anti-matter
cosmic rays and other galaxies matter
cosmic rays but much more relevantly
the universe used to be a lot smaller
the galaxies didn't used to be that far
away in fact they used to be a more or
less smooth homogeneous plasma and if
half of that plasma or even 10 of it
were anti-matter you would know it would
annihilate away very quickly into super
high energy radiation and the microwave
background would look like a very very
different place so there's no realistic
possibility that there's large
collections of anti-matter here in our
universe today
now I think I'm going to group these
three together yeah red and tanov
Antonov
says what was the question Rafael buso
was begging at the 109 Mark that you
left for an in-person discussion
Sid Huff says I enjoyed your recent
podcast with Rafael Busa I gather that
you and he disagree on certain aspects
of quantum mechanics among other things
at one point you commented that you
would table that discussion for a later
time can you highlight for us the two or
three issues that you and he hold
substantively different views on and why
you think that is
and Michael pickle says in the episode
with Rafael buso you pressed a bit to
get an answer to your question regarding
whether we are more likely to live in a
three plus one dimensional world or a
lower dimensional world the basis for
the question seemed to be that there are
differences in the way one or the other
reality would appear to us I have
thought that the equivalence of the two
models means that they would appear the
same to us that if we were beings living
in ads or CFT the appearance of the
world around us would stay the same am I
looking at that the wrong way so for
future reference
um I like Michael's version of this the
best followed by Reds followed by SIDS
not because the questions are any
different in substance but because you
can't expect me to remember a certain
comment that I made in a podcast weeks
ago especially when we recorded that
podcast with Raphael I think in July or
something like that I've just been
having to delay posting it because there
were other people who had books coming
out Etc so if you want me to read I love
it when people ask you know talk about
this specific point of this specific
podcast but you have to remind me of
exactly what was being talked about I'm
not just gonna remember you know Raphael
and I agree on lots of things like I
hope people don't get the wrong
impression here you know because the
research that we do is so similar to
each other's we can get into very very
specific kinds of disagreements in ways
that you know Margaret Levy and I or
Danny Bassett or Perry zern and I are
just not going to get into because I'm
an outsider in their research
um but with Raphael like we've both been
thinking about this for decades now and
we can get down into the weeds a little
bit so even though we do disagree about
things probably our overall level
agreement is substantially higher than
those of two randomly chosen people in
this subfield so I don't even think that
we were disagreeing about this except
for maybe the significance of the
question and the question was if you
believe in dualities okay which you
should so a duality is basically two
different classical descriptions of the
same underlying single quantum
mechanical theory in the case of ads CFT
there's a single theory that looked at
in a certain way looks like a Quantum
field Theory without gravity the CFT and
looked at in a different way the same
exact Theory looks like a theory with
gravity in anti-decider space and
mathematically they're the same but if
you think that something like that is
supposed to apply to the real world
then you realize that you know we've
gone thousands of years thinking that
the world looks a certain way and if we
now discover that you can think of it in
a different way there's a question which
is why didn't we think of that of it in
the different way from the start why did
we find ourselves very naturally in a
world with gravity if there's another
description of ourselves in a world
without gravity and I think that this is
a tricky question and I think there's
different aspects coming into it and the
adscft version of the question is pretty
darn well defined you know there's two
theories there's a theory of ads with
gravity theory on the boundary with one
less Dimension no gravity
if there were people if there were
living beings in that world they would
almost to answer Michael's question they
would not see both any more than we see
both in uh our universe because people
think that we have holographic duels
that are mathematical descriptions but
there is a first way that you sort of
obviously just using your nose perceive
around you that the world is and I think
that uh complex living beings in this
universe would either think they were
living in anti-decider space or in a
flat space conformal field Theory so why
what are the criteria that picks out one
over the other and I think there's two
things going on Raphael didn't answer it
but here's my half-baked answer which I
don't think is quite complete
part of it is comes down to what we call
strong coupling right you know famously
in uh the world in which we live in the
standard model of particle physics we're
very very lucky that the fine structure
constant of electromagnetism is one
divided by 137 which is a small number
it's less than one percent because what
that means is that we can accurately
model the world to first order in that
parameter Alpha the fine structure
constant so in quantum mechanics in
Feynman diagram language there are
electromagnetic interactions that are
proportional to Alpha to find structure
constant 1 over 137 then there are
corrections to those interactions that
are proportional to Alpha squared Alpha
cubed Etc but because Alpha is small
those higher order Corrections are very
small and we can get pretty far ignoring
them so there's sort of a natural
language that we can use and very often
in these dualities if you're strong if
you're weakly coupled like that that's a
weak couplings small coupling constant
if your weekly couple on one side of The
Duality you're strongly coupled on the
other and in a strong coupling world
it's just harder to make sense of the
world you know you can't use a classical
approximation in a very easy way and
therefore it's harder to know what any
beings would say about the world and so
maybe it's just easier to live on the
weak coupling side of the duality
but there's another aspect to that which
is a little bit more murky which is
classicality depends on decoherence
right classicality is the emergence of a
limit
from uh of quantum mechanics and it's a
limit that depends on things like The
Arrow of time right if there's no Arrow
of time between thermal equilibrium
things would not look classical at all
so that's much more murky to me I think
there's work to be done there it's one
of the things that I personally am
interested in thinking about more
um how can what role does d coherence
and branching of the wave function have
in what we call classical and therefore
in which side of a duality would we find
ourselves living on because maybe the
ability to think of our world as
classical plays a really important role
and their decoherence is important again
I don't know but that's what I'm sort of
wondering about and asking questions of
my podcast guests
Murray Dunn says is there anything that
can absorb reflect or refract
gravitational waves or do they propagate
undisturbed until the end of time well
you know gravitational waves interact
with matter they do
um just like electromagnetic waves do I
shouldn't say just like I like but not
exactly just like the crucially
crucially important difference and I've
emphasized this uh in many different
contexts is that in electromagnetism you
have positive charges and negative
charges and by subtly mixing up the
configuration of the positive charges
and negative charges you can basically
create or cancel out any electromagnetic
field you want in particular you can
absorb or reflect okay whereas
gravitational charges are just the
masses of the particles that you're
making up your system from and those are
always positive gravity is always
attractive if there's no repulsive
gravitational force between two ordinary
particles and so it is enormously harder
to manipulate gravitational waves I mean
that plus of course the fact that
gravity is just a really weak Force so
that also makes it very very hard so
therefore to a really good approximation
gravitational waves just propagate
undisturbed until the end of time they
will of course be deflected by other
gravitational fields there's
gravitational lensing of gravitational
waves but reflecting them is almost
impossible to do because they will they
will lose energy as a gravitational wave
passes through you know a cloud of gas
or whatever it exerts energy on the
cloud and therefore loses energy itself
but that effect is super duper really
tiny it's not one that you really have
to take into account as a working
astronomer
Igor villotic says when you discussed
earlier the boltzmann brain problem you
mentioned the issue with the random
fluctuation of the laws of logic and
reasoning given that you are not a
boltzmann brain how would you generally
justify the use of logic the way you use
it could you do it without using some
kind of logic
so I'm not sure if this is mostly a
question about logic or mostly a
question about boltzmann brains
um I'm not sure and I'm also not sure
what you mean by the word justify it's
not your fault it's a perfectly
well-formed question but I think that
this is an example where
being really really specific about the
meaning of those kinds of words matters
um you know I don't necessarily justify
the use of logic other than by saying
that it works in other words look maybe
I am a boltzmann brain maybe I am a
brain in a vat or maybe I live in a
simulation and the whole world was
created last Thursday like all of these
are logically possible but they're no
way to go lit on living right there's no
way to go through life uh if they're
true then there's certain things that
are just out of my control and I can't
do anything about them so there's a very
down to earth pragmatic question how do
we model our world what and what we mean
by that is what are the useful ways to
model the world that we can imagine
and part of those useful ways are you
know we want our model of the world to
be compatible with the data and to be
simple and useful and fruitful and
understandable and all those things
um but it's more than that right so it's
there are there might be multiple models
of the world that are compatible with
the data that have very different levels
of usefulness if they are true right so
the thing about logic and the thing
about not being a boltzmann brain is if
they're not true if logic is false if I
am just a boltzmann brain they're not
things are hopeless I don't know what's
going to happen next I have no reason to
trust any of my thoughts Etc whereas if
I hypothesize that my impressions of the
world are roughly correct my knowledge
of logic is roughly on the right track
then I can make progress maybe it's true
maybe it's not but that's how I'm going
to act
Nate wadups says do you think that wider
adoption of ranked Choice voting or
approval voting could mitigate the
polarization that plagues politics and
discourse in the United States these
days
well I'm not I don't have a favorite
Theory honestly I don't have a favorite
solution
um I think that ranked Choice voting has
its issues as we've discussed before
um some kind of approval voting or range
voting score voting might be the right
way to go but I'm very open to the
possibility that they're simply
practical worries about that asking
everyone to sort of carry through that
more complicated voting procedure uh in
a big country heterogeneous country like
the United States might be very very
difficult to do so there might just be
practical questions of implementation
that I don't know about so right now I'm
very much in the stage of thinking about
different possibilities and being open
to different possibilities rather than
having settled on the one true answer to
these difficult questions
Gregory kushnick says mobsters and
tyrants know that the most effective
deterrent is to punish the families of
miscreants but civilized folks of all
ethical Persuasions reject that option
which suggests that some notion of
dessert I.E what people deserve is still
in play even for free will Skeptics
attempts to frame this rejection as
consequentialism it would be bad to live
in a society that embraced punishment of
the innocent seems like question begging
it's our intuitions about dessert that
make it seem bad what's your take on
this conundrum well
I'm not a free will skeptic and I'm not
100 a consequentialist either so I think
that there is Free Will and I'm not
completely a consequentialist in this
extent that I want to live in a world
where people have rights okay and
certain rights shouldn't be trampled on
even if you could make an argument that
it would be better for the rest of
society again I don't think this is easy
I don't have a simple way of talking
about this or a final answer that I want
to push on everybody else except to
emphasize that it's not easy that it is
complicated it is subtle we have to
think through the subtleties here we
can't just climb onto some easy answer
because it gives us Clarity so yeah I
don't want to live in a world where you
deter deter bad behavior by punishing
innocent people and even if that gives
you the best consequentialist answer and
of course you know someone like Josh
Green who he talked to a year ago and I
mentioned it in the introduction what he
would say is really if you work through
it the true consequences of policy like
that are actually not so good because
people would rise up against the
dictator or whatever and you know that
you could make some argument I'm a
little bit fishy about uh skeptical
about that I don't know I think that
might be sort of wanting to get a
certain answer and then convincing
yourself that it's right but then again
I haven't thought of it carefully enough
to know for sure so my short answer
would be free will is is fine it's real
it's emergent higher level
compatibleist version of free will but I
think it's there and consequentialism is
not the final answer there are reasons
to treat people with dignity and respect
over and above simple consequentialist
calculus
Richard King asks a priority question is
it true that all life forms are survival
driven converters and responders of
varying complexity hint the answer is
yes well I don't know is my answer uh
because number one I'm not quite sure
what converters and responders mean uh
varying complexity yes life forms have
varying complexity do they convert
things you know I guess maybe usually I
don't know want to know if that's an
absolute part of being a life form I
would be willing to think that it is but
I don't have a very strong opinion about
it responders is it more difficult
question it depends on your definition
of response survival driven I think is
is pretty dubious you first have to
posit that there are drives that there
is what dandenna would call the
intentional stance that you can
attribute to something like a bacterium
and then that these drives are oriented
in the direction of survival which is
going to largely be true but not all the
time there's plenty of times when people
do things that are counter to their
individual survival so again I think
that it's complicated and I think we
should embrace the complexity in
situations like this
Sam Hartzog says in your opinion what
role should government play in
regulating illicit drugs controlled
substances and dietary supplements in
general is it possible even in principle
to ground drug prohibitions scheduling
decisions on objective research given
the nature of the questions involved you
know sure yes I do think it is possible
in principle to ground these things on
objective research now the reason one
would ask a question like that is
because traditionally they've not always
been grounded on objective research
there's been a lot of fear-mongering and
bad policy about drugs in general and
that is held back scientific research no
doubt so we could be a lot closer to
grounding things on objective research
but we should also mention that it's
never always objective research you know
objective research tells us scientific
facts it doesn't give us
ought right we're not going to derive an
ought from these is so what are you
going to do with your objective research
you need some goals how much Freedom
should you give individual people to
ruin their own lives I think once again
that's a perfectly legitimate difficult
question I think that makes sense to
regulate uh drugs substances dietary
supplements that might be legitimately
unhealthy and people might not recognize
it you know there's a losing weight pill
that five months after you take it as a
hundred percent fatality rate I think
it's okay for the government to ban
something like that right these are
subtle questions I think that I I'm in
favor of legalization of a lot more
controlled substances that are legalized
right now
but I recognize the difficulties
involved
Taryn says David Hume challenged the
Primacy of pure logical thinking when he
says reason is and ought only to be the
slave of the passions to what extent do
you agree with this view well I'm not
sure if it's the Primacy of pure logical
thinking that he was challenging I think
he's just pointing out it's not the only
kind of thing so I mean he you know
David Hume famously tried his best in a
sort of charming way to be a gripping
writer uh and never quite succeeded so
it actually worked against him because
he was sometimes like colorful and cute
in ways that got in the way of what he
was saying so slave of the passions is
is an example of that
what I think what he's saying is you can
logic your way into any conclusion you
want uh or any true conclusion you know
it does say that you're doing it
correctly okay you're doing logic
correctly it still doesn't tell you how
to act why because you can't derive
ought from his as was pointed out by
David Hume this is the angle that he's
trying to get at here you still need to
have some motivation some goals some
values okay and those values are not
derivable in any direct unique way from
objective facts about the world
you can change your values even though
the objective acts of the world don't
change and so that's what he means by
the passions in this case basically what
he's saying is we have passions that
tell us what we want logic is going to
tell us how to get it okay so it's not
really slavery as the actual
relationship here but we put logic to
work to get what we want logic does not
tell us what we want and I do agree with
that view
Bart Connolly says once per lifetime
question as I enjoyed your podcast with
Alan Lightman I'm wondering if you have
any further thoughts on how conscious
beings can best pursue spiritual
interests in the material world should
we just regard them as something to
outgrow or perhaps should we find ways
using disciplines like meditation and
Technology to pursue this goal much as
we use science and technology to help
with physical health
I think this is another subtle question
because I think that it's going to
depend a lot on what you mean by the
word spiritual with which BART put in
quotes in his question quite uh
correctly I personally don't ever like
to use the word spiritual in this
context because you have to really
contort yourself into a weird definition
of spiritual in order to make sense
I am going to be someone who says that
when you use the word spiritual people
are going to think of spirits they're
going to think of these Spirits as
non-physical non-natural manifestations
and if you don't want them to think
about that if you want to be purely
naturalist in your inclinations don't
use the word spiritual okay use some
other word what word should you use
sadly I don't know I don't have an
opinion about that but I take that you
know what the important point of Alan
lightman's discussion was is that there
are experiences that we have there are
feelings that we have there are values
that we have as human beings that we
human beings struggle to put into clear
crisp naturalistic language and so we
can group them into a bucket that if you
want to label it spiritual I'm not happy
with it but you know go ahead I can't
stop you from doing that
um and these feelings of you know
Oneness with the universe Transcendence
or whatever on the one hand have zero
incompatibility with nature or the laws
of nature there's no evidence that there
is a world Beyond physics just because
on a certain Starlet night when I'm
looking at the sky I feel one with the
universe okay that's not actual
refutation of naturalism but on the
other hand they can still be important
you can still value them you can still
think that people will be better off if
they spend time commuting with nature
and becoming one with the universe
rather than uh insulting people on
Twitter or something like that so I I
think that we yeah this is part of the
reason why I do things like organize
that Beyond or moving naturalism forward
Workshop that I organized way back when
2012 something like that
um because I do think that our
vocabulary isn't up to the task we
inherit this vocabulary from how we were
thinking about things a thousand years
ago
and we we know better now but the words
in the language hasn't haven't caught up
yet and so I don't know how what the
right words to use would be but I don't
think the right answer is just to use
the old words and with a wink and a
nudge and say but you know what I mean I
don't really mean that I think we should
be able to do better than that
David Maxwell says your breadth of
interests makes me tune in but it's your
ability to Simply communicate complex
ideas across a range of topics that
makes you unique to me an interviewee
can speak for 10 minutes and you'll
distill it in a way that crystallizes my
understanding and that your guests often
want to borrow how do you do it do you
think things through and through or come
up with simple ways to understand do you
ever pre-write your amazing reductive
statements or is it just the way you
think perhaps a product of your Fields
physics particularly with a mind to
complexity so thank you for the very
nice words David uh I usually actually
don't like to read questions with you
know the compliments embedded in the
beginning that's not why we're here in
the amas but in this case there is an
interesting question here
um and I don't completely know the
answer to but I don't think it's any
super duper special ability on my own I
think there's two things going on one
very down to earth thing is
mindscape Enterprises worldwide is still
very much a one-person shop it's just me
and what that means is that I'm not you
know a radio host or even many
podcasters who have a producer or a
Booker who is getting guests on the show
the guests I get are all invited by me
personally and they're invited by me
because I'm interested in what they have
to say so I don't need to like pretend
to be interested in what they have to
say every single person who comes on has
some knowledge that I want to get to and
so I'm motivated to try to understand it
better myself and the other aspect is
you know yeah whether it's physics or
complexity or just being in Academia and
well at the at the intersection of being
in Academia doing research and also
public discussion and communication
um it trains you to distill things down
right you can understand something well
number one it's hard to understand
things you have to work at it number two
you can understand things and still fail
in the attempt to communicate those
things to other people and I've been
trying to do both of those things for a
very long time I'm old now I've been
around the block not my first rodeo
didn't just fall off the turnip truck
and so I've had practice doing exactly
this and not to you know to to I should
emphasize something very importantly
other people have also done that but I
care about doing it well so I try so I
think about how I do it and uh you know
I think about how to distill these
difficult ideas down I do not pre-write
anything I have like one page of little
bullet point notes generally going into
a podcast but certainly no phrases or
anything like that are pre-planned but
as the person is talking I'm trying very
hard to understand what they say and to
distill it down put it into my own words
uh based on a lifetime of trying to take
difficult Concepts and put them into
words that other people can understand
and very often and this happens vice
versa two other people say things about
my work that I go yeah you know that's a
good way of putting it like if you're in
the weeds if you're doing something
every day and thinking about it you can
get into ruts you can think about things
using a certain set of words using a
certain set of moves if you will and
they're just so useful to you that you
can't sort of jump out and put things in
another way and talking to someone else
who really cares about the ideas can
help you put things in a different way
because they haven't been in those ruts
the whole time
Jim Watson says understanding that
models generally have a domain of
applicability for accuracy or at least
efficient calculation I'm curious how
useful our lowest level Quantum models
are for explaining things at the level
of chemistry or Material Science for
example can one start with the electron
wave equations or electromagnetic force
calculations and derive how covalent
bonding of shared electrons across atoms
works or that the carbon lattice would
be super hard or stress versus strain of
iron Etc uh yeah actually again this is
an example of something that is not
precisely my domain of expertise but yes
these are the kinds of things that you
can actually derive using the principles
of atomic physics and quantum mechanics
there's a whole field of density
functional theory that tries to make
these calculations easier the problem is
that quantum mechanics lives in Hilbert
space Hilbert's face is very very big
even when you have a small number of
particles the calculational difficulty
of following the quantum equations
becomes very very difficult so that's
okay you derive approximation methods uh
density functional theory is one such
thing but also you have sort of higher
level models that glue onto the lower
level models so things like BCS
superconductivity and things like that
are higher level versions of
nevertheless manifestations of the
quantum phenomena from the lower level
so it's generally not true that you try
to derive detailed things about you know
how why spaghetti splits into three
pieces when you break it rather than
just two starting with the standard
model of particle physics but you build
your way up right and actually you can
build your way up surprisingly far just
from the fundamental Quantum description
the calculational complexity of doing
that is of course one of the major
reasons why we're interested in building
quantum computers people talk about
quantum computers in terms of
cryptography or teleportation or
whatever the real obvious killer app for
quantum computers is simulating quantum
systems probably difficult chemistry is
an obvious thing to aim at but Material
Science and things like that will also
be looked at
James mackrell says priority question
I've read many articles and listened to
many discussions that lead me to wonder
what is meant by the cosmos is a
hologram or a computer program made by
some master programmer please decipher
are those describing actual processes or
is all of this talk an attempt to
describe the cosmos in understandable
terms well the two things that you
mentioned there are very very different
the cosmos is a hologram and the cosmos
is a computer programmer made by some
master programmer the latter bit the
idea that we're a computer programmer is
supposed to be you know a serious
suggestion for the fundamental nature of
reality the simulation argument it's
usually called one that we have no
evidence is correct but it's possible
people differ on whether how plausible
it is the cosmos is a hologram is an
entirely different idea I mean we might
have in mind the kinds of holograms we
can buy in a toy store or whatever that
were clearly constructed by somebody but
this is not trying to say that the
Hologram is in any sense built by some
higher Intel or anything like that it's
just the idea that there's an
alternative description of reality that
encodes all the information about our
world in a space that has one fewer
Dimension than the space that we seem to
live in ourselves that's what we were
talking about we were talking about
Rafael buso's discussion and ads CFT
again we don't know that that's true or
not either but there's evidence for that
one at least there's very good reasons
to believe that some kind of holographic
behavior is part of our best
understanding of quantum gravity but
it's all very mechanistic and it's just
talking about a different way of
describing the same fundamental stuff
schleier says I read and enjoyed the
biggest ideas in the universe volume one
so I followed the math laboriously the
one problem I have is that when dealing
with formulas my mind goes into similar
symbol manipulation mode which I find
can't co-exist with understanding the
significance mode are you able to do the
math while keeping the big picture in
mind or is it normal to kind of toggle
back and forth
so I'm not exactly sure what you mean
there's certainly a mode where you're
just pushing around symbols that is
absolutely true but it doesn't seem to
me at least to be exclusive with the
mode where you're understanding what's
going on in fact I think that at some
point when you become practiced enough
with the equations and with the symbols
you become frustrated when there are no
equations I know that this is often a
frustration I have in reading some
philosophy papers that you know like I
think the ideas are right but I would
like to see some equations that I'm sure
that I'm following the argument as
clearly as I am so I don't think that
it's a matter of toggling back and forth
I do think that again you can solve
equations like when you're halfway
through calculating the Riemann tensor
you can't point to one term and say I
know the significance of this it doesn't
have any significance it's just part of
uh decomposition it's like when you have
the number 10 and someone says well I'm
going to think of that as four plus six
they're welcome to do this but it's 10
that matters it's not the fact that one
person has four plus six is the way they
got there right likewise when you're in
the middle of a calculation very often
the intermediate steps don't have any
physical significance but you should be
able to attach some meaning to the final
answer as well as to the starting point
I think that's just something you get
better at with time
Benjamin cowger asks a priority question
I personally always struggled with the
general two-dimensional diagram of
gravity the standard bowling ball in a
trampoline image ingrained in everyone's
minds and in most school books and
online it seems most folks I've taught
with think of gravity this way as a ball
on a rubber sheet and it's been tough to
explain gravity as a force acting on and
curving 3D space if you layer in 4D
space time and how gravity acts upon it
it gets even harder to explain in words
why is the ball in the sheet the
standard go-to image in most all
articles books documentaries Etc
well
it's hard to explain the curvature of
four-dimensional space-time in terms
that would be familiar to people most
people have a difficult time visualizing
curved four-dimensional space time so we
reach for analogies and metaphors and
visualizations and things like that and
that's perfectly okay as long as you are
clear about what the limitations of the
analogy are uh there's a famous XKCD
cartoon by former mindscape guest
Randall Monroe where someone a professor
uses the rubber sheet analogy to explain
gravity and then someone raises their
hand in the audience and says that's not
possible because the bowl is embedded in
a three-dimensional space and it's only
a two-dimensional space that is moving
and the professor says okay well what we
really mean is there's something called
the Riemann tensor and we can track that
to get the Einstein tensor and the
audience like no no we didn't want that
either
you have to you know work your way from
the picturesque metaphors to the exact
equations and different metaphors and
visualizations and analogies are going
to be useful to different people so I'm
always of the opinion that you should
use all of them and be very very clear
about what the limitations are so you
know I'm on record as to really not
liking the expanding balloon analogy for
the universe but I see why you would
want to use it as long as you're super
clear about its limitations I feel
likewise about the ball on a sheet it's
trying to illustrate the fact that a
massive object can warp the space around
it right and it's only doing it
metaphorically not directly you have to
both trust the audience to be able to
see that distinction and help them see
it by explaining why you're doing this
you don't just say here's the ball in
the sheet space time is like that trust
me
Seth holowico says I know that you loved
knives out there's a semi-sequel out and
I just went to see it what are your
thoughts on movie franchises versus
one-off original movies and if you've
seen the new Knives Out movie Glass
Onion what did you think Ryan Johnson is
so darn clever and I wish that more
directors were being so creative
yeah you know I almost never uh admit to
this kind of thing but I did ask the
publicity people at Netflix whether Ryan
Johnson could come on the Netflix on the
the mindscape podcast and they never
wrote back to me so I didn't ask I don't
know Ryan Johnson personally I didn't
ask him himself but Ryan if you're out
there listening to the AMA would love
you to have you on the show anytime
someone pointed out by the way that in
the very first episode zero of mindscape
I I extended invitation to Lady Gaga to
come on the mindscape podcast and that
also continues to be true Lady Gaga if
you want to come on the podcast we'd
love to talk to you but yeah uh for
anyone who doesn't know Ryan Johnson who
uh has directed a lot of movies spanning
quite a space
um has a sequel out to the original
Knives Out from a couple years ago the
new one is called Glass Onion they're
both murder mysteries starring uh Daniel
Craig as Benoit bronc who is a Kentucky
detective so it did take me a while I
will admit to adjust to hearing Daniel
Craig talk in a ridiculously
over-the-top Kentucky accent during the
movie but you get into it very quickly
and it's clearly easily no question
Daniel Craig's best roles ever and I
love the fact that there's sequels to
this kind of thing I think that whether
or not you have sequels to movies or
original movies as one-off Standalone
pictures depends an enormous amount on
the material right I mean there's plenty
of things where
especially not just with movies but with
you know limited series uh TV shows
where there's a novel and they based a
six or ten part TV show on the novel and
they keep going because you know once
you've set up everything it's cheaper to
just have a season two in a season three
and it often doesn't work very well
because it's not following the novel
anymore and that's a clear example where
you should just stick with the original
material but Ryan Johnson is clearly
having enormous fun with the genre of
mystery novels which is also one of my
favorite genres and he does it in an
updated post-modern kind of way so he's
not slavishly following the tropes of
the mystery novel he's playing with them
and it's just brilliantly creative and
hilarious I think I would give a slight
Edge to knives out over a Glass Onion
but I love them both enormously I saw
that and uh another movie called the
menu with Anna Taylor joy and Nicholas
Holt and Ray fines and that I won't
spoil it for anyone but that was also an
amazingly good movie just came out this
week or last week unlike Glass Onion I
cannot recommend the menu unreservedly
because really it was written for me
that movie it's a dark comedy about
upscale Cuisine and various other
jokes about race and class and things
like that and it was all very very well
done and the acting was amazing and I
loved it but other people might not like
it whereas everyone will love Glass
Onion I think
Phil Hamilton says if it turns out that
a non-material Essence God created the
universe from nothing how would
scientists be able to differentiate that
from the universe having spontaneously
appeared from nothing it seems that
evidence of these two possible origins
of the universe would appear the same to
scientists
yeah it's a perfectly reasonable
question and I think that it depends on
both our future good understanding of
the laws of physics and maybe hopefully
our future better understanding of God
you know the problem with God as a
hypothesis to explain features of the
physical world is it's just way too
ill-defined you know you say Okay God
created the universe okay what kind of
universe would God create and why and
these are very very hard questions to
answer whereas with laws of physics you
can say oh yes according to these
equations the universe would be created
this way rather than that way so that's
why I think that there's just sort of a
prior preference for purely naturalistic
explanations when you can find them but
maybe in the course of your
investigations you just come up across a
roadblock you say look I've we've tried
as hard as we can we cannot come up with
a set of laws of physics that both fit
our universe as we currently understand
it and allow for the universe to have an
initial
Moment by the way parenthetically
created out of nothing is a terrible
terrible way of saying it the universe
is not created out of nothing the
question is did it have an initial
moment or did it last forever that is
the distinction and if we cannot find
reasonable uh equations or models or
theories that explain the universe
either eternally lasting all by itself
or having an initial moment then we
might conclude that the best theory we
have is that God did it we might
maintain some uncertainty about that
right we may say well we don't know
the thing about God is it would be super
duper easy for God to make perfectly
clear to us that he exists and he's
chosen not to do that so I'm going to
count that as evidence against his
existence
Nick C says when you take a class in
physics you might learn about Newtonian
mechanics electromagnetism relativity
Etc but you don't gently read the
original writings of Newton Maxwell
Einstein Etc you usually read modern
texts by contrast when I took philosophy
classes we generally read the original
historical works of great philosophers
especially in light of your new academic
position I'd be curious to hear your
thoughts on whether this distinction
between the approaches of physics
philosophy is generally true why it's
true and whether either discipline
should emulate the approach of the other
more
yeah I think that I'm sort of
sympathetic with the general tone of
your question which I take to be that
um the reason why in physics we
generally read modern textbooks rather
than the original writings is because
the ideas are there they exist
independently the person who came up
with them and in fact we generally
understand the ideas better than the
people who came up with them because
we've had more time to think about it to
really dig into it to get the notation
right all those things as I've often
said I understand general relativity
better than Einstein did in some ways
anyway because I'm standing on the
shoulders of other Giants not because
I'm especially smart myself
whereas philosophy that's much less
common it is not at all absent there's
plenty of discussion of ideas and
philosophy from secondary literature Etc
you know plenty of people writing
articles other than the the greats of uh
the history of philosophy but you're
right we we read The Originals much more
often in philosophy than in physics and
in part that's because the well it
depends very much on the specific kind
of philosophy you're talking about
if you're doing mathematical Logic for
example uh you're more likely honestly
to read a textbook in mathematical logic
than you are to read girdle's original
papers on girdle's theorem or Russell
and Whitehead's principia Mathematica
Etc but in some kinds of philosophy it's
thought that it is hard to get it right
by translating what someone said into
one's own language and therefore the
original text really matters and is
important and I think that's done too
much honestly a little bit but not that
much because I get it it depends on what
kind of philosophy you're talking about
as I said but in some areas a philosophy
it is really hard to capture those ideas
exactly and different people can read
the same text and get a slightly
different opinion about what is going on
in them
that is partly because not every
philosopher is a great writer just like
not every physicist is partly because
the ideas are just very very hard
so I would argue that both Fields could
learn a little bit from each other I
think that philosophers well I'm less
interested in the history of philosophy
than the average philosopher is I want
to use philosophy to move forward to
improve our understanding and not just
to improve our understanding of past
philosophers but to improve our
understanding of the fundamental nature
of reality that's that's my personal
goal but physicists you know they could
do a much better job at understanding
their history you know they butcher
Butcher their history pretty badly and
it does lead to sort of lingering
misunderstandings that can last for a
very long time so maybe a little bit
more of if not the original
um writers than at least the history of
what how they were thinking would be
good for physics I think
grouping two questions together Redmond
says has the FTX debacle affected your
view of effective altruism and Nick B
says can one person Define or destroy a
philosophical position unfortunately for
will mccaskill effective altruism has a
new face Sam bankman freed I'm sorry I
don't know if it's freed or fried that
he pronounces name freed I think he has
made it world famous what has had been
presented as a logical and potent
approach for doing the most good for the
most people now and in the future is
currently being criticized as
utilitarianism with a God complex and
bunk does its rapid Fall From Grace
demonstrate an inherently flawed
perspective or his effective altruism
robust enough to withstand the collapse
of FTX so I think there's a lot going on
here these are perfectly good questions
to ask uh you know my own relationship
to effective altruism has been cautious
interest I've never been you know part
of what is called the effective altruism
Community uh effective altruism is an
approach to to altruism which tries to
make it effective okay so you say yes
it's good to give the charity but some
Charities do more than others as we
talked about way in the introduction of
this podcast and I've talked about it
with uh will mccaskill recently but also
Josh green and other people on the
podcast look
starting from scratch I would rather my
altruism be effective than ineffective
so that's good now there's a couple of
caveats there one is that you can go too
far you can uh much of effective
altruism is based on a utilitarian
perspective and as I've said before I'm
not really a utilitarian I have a
utilitarian uh sympathies in certain
directions but I'm not a fully going
utilitarian I thought that hopefully
that came out in the conversation with
Will mccaskill
um that I tried to bring up some of the
possible objections here to long-termism
and effective altruism and the second
aspect that is raised is that there is
something called the effective altruism
community
and I think it's very very important to
separate the ideas from the community
I'm not even sure it's healthy that
there is a community you know there's a
certain in-groupiness there's a certain
US versus them you know the In Crowd
versus the normies kind of vibe that
comes into the game when you have a
community but also communities can do
good and work together and and have an
effect on the world you know effective
altruism has had much more of an effect
on the world than I have for better for
worse do I think that the malfeasance of
Samuel bankman freed has changed things
you know for those of you who don't know
uh Sam bankman freed AKA SBF uh is
someone who made a lot of money in
cryptocurrency exchange called FTX and
was also very vocal proponent of
effective altruism and turns out to be a
huge fraudster and lost billions of
dollars for himself and for other people
and so the question is does this
undermine a factor of altruism well it
doesn't undermine the I idea of the
factor of altruism in any possible way I
think I mean the fact that some bad
actor holds an idea in my view doesn't
affect whether the idea is right or
wrong at all it might
undermines one confidence in the one's
confidence in the Judgment of people in
the community the effect of altruism
community that they went along with uh
such an obvious fraudster from the start
I mean it was it's kind of a yeah it I
think that the psychology there the
story is very very interesting
um Michael Lewis you know who wrote
Moneyball and the big short and all
those things I don't know how he does it
I don't know how Michael Lewis does it
he hasn't nose for these things he was
literally embedded in FTX while it was
collapsing and he's going to write about
it I'm sure what he writes will turn out
to be fascinating reading
um so but that's the story about human
psychology and how we can get caught up
in wishful thinking and therefore be
susceptible to frauds and Liars more
than it is a story about effective
altruism so my personal feelings about
effective altruism are entirely
unchanged namely that I'm sympathetic to
some of its statements without being a
full-fledged member of the community or
complete believer in it I think that
things are a little bit more complicated
than the typical effective altruist
would
have you believe I mean I guess I should
I should mention what I take to be the
most effective
critique of effect of altruism
going all the way back to Peter singer
who's sort of The Godfather of the whole
movement which is that there's just a
lot of emphasis here on charitable
giving and charitable giving is good but
it in many ways doesn't change the world
you know like sometimes we have
systematic problems that need some
systematic upheaval and you know giving
money to this or that non-government
organization that is doing good is not
addressing the underlying systematic
issues that doesn't mean it's bad to do
it I think that you know saving people
from malaria is still important even if
the systematic problems are still there
you just can't let it be a distraction
from the fact that there are more
systematic ways to change things that
will ultimately have a bigger impact
P Walder says can you explain the
difference between relativistic and
constructivist foundations for Morality
I think yeah this is actually a case
where more or less the words are
accurate when you talk about moral
relativism what you're saying is that
morality is relative to the beliefs of
some Community or something like that
right if a community decides that
something is moral then it's moral
that's what it means to be moral and
people who are outside the community
have nothing to say about that have no
rights no leverage to critique it
whereas constructivism is just saying
that morality is constructed in other
words it's not out there in the world to
be discovered it's something that human
beings come together and individually
and collectively construct on the basis
of something and there will be a
difference between human constructivists
who think that different people might
ultimately construct different perfectly
plausible sensible reason uh versions of
morality because their individual
inclinations and their passions are
different or as a kantian constructivist
will say that there is one uniquely
rational moral system that you could
construct
but there's nothing in any of that that
says that morality is relative to some
Community or that anything could be a
decent formulation of morality as long
as some Community believes it or that
some person outside the community is not
allowed to critique it it's just
admitting that morality is not
objectively real out there in the world
like scientific facts are out there in
the world once I have my morality I'm
going to feel perfectly free to
criticize other people who don't go
along with it the critique is not on the
basis that those people are objectively
making a mistake that they're like
making a mistake if they say two plus
two equals five or the universe is
Contracting or something like that it's
a different kind of criticism it's
saying that according to my version of
morality they're doing something wrong
here's why I think my version of
morality is good that's it okay it's not
objective and foundational but I have no
reason to say I'm not allowed to make
that critique
James Allen says in the biggest ideas
you talk a lot about the value of
spherical cow thinking do you think the
reason this kind of thinking is so
effective historically and practically
is a surprising feature of our universe
or is it just a necessary feature of
anything that could be reasonably called
laws of physics I think this is a great
question I don't know the answer I mean
I think there's two aspects going on
here
um one is that well just to back up a
little bit I should say what we mean by
spherical Cloud thinking is the idea
that you can
take away many of the complications in a
system analyze a much simpler toy model
system and then put the complications
back in when you want to compare to
reality this is a technique that works
super duper well in many areas of
physics doesn't always work well in
other kinds of Sciences biology or
sociology or whatever so the aspects I
was going to mention are number one
certainly in those areas where spherical
cow thinking works it is a wonderful
technique that lets you make a lot of
progress
so when that works you're gonna
feel like you're getting further in your
in your quest to understand nature more
because nature is sort of making it easy
for you right that's why physicists are
able to go much further and develop a
lot more elaborate model building in the
world because the questions are
fundamentally simpler than questions of
biology or sociology Etc but the other
aspect is did it have to be there
did the universe have to be in such a
way that there are some aspects with the
property that they can be analyzed
effectively in this way and that's the
second part of James's question is it a
necessary feature of anything that could
be called laws of physics I don't think
that's true I don't see why there must
be a regime of the physical world which
is amenable to that kind of let's
abstract away the complications and then
let let's add it back in later kind of
reasoning but I don't know I don't have
a proof or anything like that so I think
that's an interesting question
um I suspect that the answer is that
it's not necessary that's my suspicion I
think that there probably are
alternative laws of physics that we
would still call laws of physics but
they'd be much harder to discover what
they are because everything is kind of
coupled to everything else and you can't
abstract away certain complications
um but then maybe there's always some
change of variables that make things
look simple that's what I just don't
know
so Andrew harsh says the current system
of peer-reviewed papers to get to
objective truth is this the best or
quickest way to establish scientific
truths you know I always think it's a
little bit icy to talk about truths and
objective truths in this uh matter
because I do think there are truths I do
think they're objective truths but
science doesn't get them in any
deterministic way science creeps up on
them uh in a way that might not even be
monotonic like sometimes we have
setbacks right science tries to uncover
them but it's important to distinguish
between the truths of Nature and what is
actually uncovered by science so I don't
I wouldn't say that the system of
peer-reviewed papers is trying to get to
objective truth it's just trying to
improve our success rate right make this
this point very often that
there are plenty of papers that are not
peer-reviewed and yet nevertheless are
interesting and important and true there
are plenty of papers that are
peer-reviewed and published and yet are
completely false
but overall the fraction of papers that
are period and published that are
worthwhile contributions is going to be
higher than the fraction of those that
are not peer-reviewed like if something
really matters if a certain claim in a
certain piece of scientific literature
is very very important to you
then you should more or less not care
whether it appears in a peer-reviewed
journal you should read it and
understand it and judge whether or not
it's likely to be true right and that
could be work the peer review system
like many other things is a labor-saving
device it gives you a little bit more
Credence that the result is reliable and
respectable but it is not a substance a
substitute rather for your actual
judgment among all the labor-saving
devices is it the best slash quickest
that I don't know I mean I think that
we're in a world now where technology at
least enables us to think in other ways
maybe Community or peer peer review
right like put something on the web and
let people critique it and publish those
critiques or something like that but I
really haven't put any serious thought
into what is as a practical matter the
best way to get those things done
Sandra stooki says your discussion with
Rafael buso made me think about what we
actually mean by the area of the Event
Horizon of a black hole and the volume
inside it after a bit of Googling I
found claims that the volume of a black
hole is respectively zero infinity or
large and increasing toward the future
which of these is right if any and why
you know I'm not sure but I think those
are all wrong none of those sounds right
to me certainly zero and infinity are
wrong
um but it depends I mean it's not
actually a well-posed question that's
why you can get these different answers
so think about what you mean by area and
volume area is pretty well defined right
because we have the notion of the rest
frame of a black hole and in that rest
frame we have the Event Horizon and that
event horizon has an area and we can
measure it or we can determine what it
is using features of the black hole the
volume inside in the context of
Relativity is going to depend on how you
divide space time up into space and time
volume is a feature of space not of
space-time
there is something called space time
volume but uh that's a trick that's not
usually what people have in mind when
you talk about the volume of a black
hole and
so how you slice space time is going to
matter a lot to this question of what
the volume of the black hole is I think
that depending on what kind of black
hole you have if the black hole is more
or less old and stationary and you're
ignoring Hawking radiation and things
like that there will be some constant
number that you can attach to that but
it still will depend on how you do the
slicing it might not be unique
um certainly it's not zero or Infinity
uh and I don't even think it's large
increasing toward the future unless
maybe they have an idea that the black
hole is growing because matter is
falling into it maybe that's what they
have in mind but really the answer is
you should think about space-time rather
than volumes of space
Paul Hardy says what are your two or
three best arguments to Discount all the
claims that astrology makes I want to
use them on people who are immune to
science and evidence so I will first
start by saying to Paul like you've
probably already lost if you start by
saying I want to use them on people who
are immune to science and evidence
number one I don't think anyone is
immune to science and evidence and
number two if you think of the people
you're talking to in that way you're not
going to change their mind about
anything I mean maybe they are immune to
whatever you have to say in which case
why are you trying to use anything on
them why are you bothering talking to
them right the people who are worth
talking to in the world are those who
are willing to listen and think and
contemplate about what you're saying
those people are not immune to science
and evidence so I think a little bit of
humility is called for here you should
ask you know what is it that causes this
person to have a belief in astrology
where did that belief come from you
can't just quote facts at them or or
science at them and expect them to go
along with your Superior knowledge
but personally on the substantive level
here
my objections to astrology are the same
as my objections to telekinesis Etc
namely that it violates the laws of
physics there is no way for forces to
pass between celestial objects and us
here on Earth especially not in a way
that is especially important at the
moment of your birth rather than the
moment of your conception or the moment
of your high school prom or anything
like that we know what the long-range
forces are they're gravity and
electromagnetism and in both cases
nearby effects are enormously more
important than the effects of other
celestial bodies so it is much easier
for me to just believe the laws of
physics as we currently understand them
and discount the predictions that appear
in newspaper astrology columns then
overthrow the laws of physics for such
flimsy reasons
siraj Rajan says in episode 200 the solo
episode on many worlds you allude to the
many worlds literally coming into being
when you do an experiment and they are
not located anywhere they just exist
simultaneously assuming space is
emergent to these parallel universes
that come into existence have their own
emergent space all self-contained in
them is that aspect also prerequisite
for these descending universes not
influencing each other so the answers
are yes and not really the the motto is
that the universe is in many worlds do
not exist within some space space exists
within them each parallel world is a
parallel world
it is a parallel copy of space-time and
all the things in it they're not
contained inside space that's not really
the reason why these descending
universes are not influencing
influencing each other though that's
just a mathematical consequence of how
decoherence works if the way if the
quantum state of the environment that is
entangled with the quaint state of the
system in your particular world is
perpendicular to the relevant state in
some other world then there's just zero
overlap between those two worlds and you
cannot interfere from one to another so
it's not specifically about the
emergence of space in any definite way
Mark shoyern says I'm curious as to how
classes are assigned to faculty at
Hopkins and Caltech as an adjunct I just
take whatever my institutions give me
I'm guessing that you get more of a say
and that your interests and preferences
are taken into account including letting
you design your own courses yes you are
correct uh in that but I don't think
it's anything special to Hopkins or
Caltech I think this is a uh tenured
senior faculty issue versus adjuncts
adjuncts are treated very badly and you
know I think that
if I were in charge of the world there'd
be fewer adjunct positions and more
permanent positions uh among
institutions of higher education here in
the United States I am still as of yet
not in charge of the world so I don't
know how to bring that about but
basically every year there is a
negotiation
um between the faculty and the
department so the department might take
the form of the department chair or some
teaching committee usually and roughly
speaking you know uh The Faculty have
put in a request I would like to teach
these courses the teaching committee
looks at them and says yes that makes
sense or no we don't need that this year
it's certainly not you just get to teach
whatever you want like someone's got to
teach junior year electromagnetism
someone's got to do that even if no one
wants to so you might get assigned that
um but people will generally try to be
good citizens and you know take some
turns teaching their favorite courses
some turns teaching the more necessary
ones and you do get the chance to design
your own courses you know since I have a
as usual with me I have like a weird
unusual position here at Hopkins as a
Homewood professor
I am not beholden to the demands of
either the physics department or the
philosophy department so basically I get
to teach what I want with the caveat
that if someone else is already teaching
it then I don't get to teach it okay but
if I designed my own course then they I
I've only been here half a year but uh
the impression is more or less I get to
do that but that is not always the case
everywhere
Jimmy says I recently learned that
Hawking radiation isn't actually
vertical particle separation but
something more like space-time abhorring
Horizons and the curvature gradients
they create and reducing its curvature
via Hawking radiation to give to rid
itself of them at least that was my
understanding can you explain the real
story of black hole evaporation and why
evaporation only occurs when Horizons
are involved for example if a planet
existed forever would it eventually
evaporate as well to eliminate the
curvature it causes
well I would this is a tricky thing
because once again the equations are
perfectly clear but the translation into
words is
imperfect necessarily okay so when you
say space-time abhors a horizon and the
curvature gradient that they create
nah that's you know true to some extent
but I wouldn't necessarily take that too
seriously for example in decider space
if you have a cosmology with nothing but
a positive cosmodial constant there are
Horizons around every location in space
but they're not abhorred and they don't
go away there is a thermal temperature
associated with them much as with a
black hole but it's a static state that
can last forever unlike a black hole so
things are subtle here okay it is a
feature of Horizons Hawking radiation
definitely does depend on the existence
of Horizons
planets and stars ordinary stars do not
have any Hocking radiation at all it's
not that they only have a little they
have zero and the point is that in all
of these cases you have quantum
mechanics you have equations of quantum
mechanics the equations of field Theory
and the Schrodinger equation for what
ever degrees of freedom you have and you
try to solve those equations in a
certain background so the background
might be the gravitational field of a
planet or it might be the gravitational
field of a black hole and what you find
is that for a planet or for a star
the quantum Fields can settle into a
vacuum state which is just static which
just doesn't evolve in time much like
the wave function of electron in a
hydrogen atom could just settle down
there and stay there forever but a black
hole is more like an unstable nucleus
right when you have the nucleus of a
particle of an atom rather that is an
unstable isotope it can sit there for a
long time but it's wave function isn't
static its wave function is always sort
of leaking out a little bit so the
experience that we have of an unstable
particle is there it is it's sitting
there for a long time and then at some
random moment we observe it to have
decayed what's really going on is
there's a wave function that is very
gently evolving over time from I have
not decayed to I have decayed okay and
that's just a feature of the local
physics of the protons and neutrons
inside the nucleus and what is stable
and what is not stable and black holes
are like that black holes do not have
solutions to the equations of quantum
mechanics that are perfectly static
around them and so they change over time
a little bit and we observe that time
Evolution as particles being emitted
from the black hole until it evaporates
away completely and yeah if as you might
suspect if that's the case you might ask
well okay are there versions of black
holes which do have stable Solutions
around them and the answer is not that
many but there are some I mean basically
what we call extremal black holes have
zero temperature and therefore do not
radiate away but we think that that's
much like zero absolute absolute zero
temperature more generally that you
can't actually get there in any physical
process so we don't think these
extremely black holes actually exist
they're sort of spherical cow thought
experiments for physicists to play with
Chris Murray says it occurred to me that
if it's possible for there to be in the
future a time machine configured to
immediately travel back to the present
there should be infinitely many such
machines in the far future like
boltzmann brains I thought the fact that
our world is not densely packed with
such time machines could be evidenced
that backward time machines are
impossible well logically no what you're
saying doesn't quite follow
um for a couple of reasons the most
important reason is that the way the
time machines would work in general
relativity if they worked at all is that
they would be connections between two
different moments in time
so you can't start in the future and
build a time machine that stretches into
the past you can't do that even in
general relativity like even giving you
all of the weirdness of negative
energies and wormholes and whatever
craziness you want to make to use to
make a time machine you can't just start
in the future and then send a tendril
back and go to the Past what you could
possibly in principle do is build a time
machine in the present
which represents a wormhole attaching
two different points in space time and
then let one of those ends of the
Wormhole stretch to the Future and now
you have a connection between the
present and the future but if you
haven't built that wormhole in the
present then it's not here and therefore
no one can come back from the future
okay you can't use a time machine in
general relativity to go back to a point
before you build the time machine that's
one thing
the other thing is uh there's no reason
to suspect that even if time machines
exist that boltzmann brain-like
fluctuations would bring them into
existence uh maybe that's something you
could contemplate but like for that the
evidence is against it okay but that
doesn't mean that backward time machines
are impossible that just means that
there aren't boltzmann brain-like
fluctuations that bring them into
existence it's certainly possible for
certain things to be possible and yet
not fluctuating into existence as I
mentioned earlier in the podcast uh Kim
body and Jason Pollock and I argue that
there are not boltzmann brain-like
fluctuations in our actual future
universe so there you go there'd be no
evidence at all one way or another about
time machines
Jonathan bird asks why would abiogenesis
ever stop abiogenesis is the origin of
life
shouldn't molecules still be coming
together to form tiny living things
somewhere on Earth what are the chances
that there were some initial conditions
that no longer exist anywhere on Earth
well
I mean there's a lot we don't know about
this also but there's a very simple
counter argument to the thought uh
experiment that you're proposing here
namely that life already exists on Earth
and has evolved for billions of years
and therefore the life that already
exists is way better than any little
proto-molecule kind of Life at competing
for the resources that we have here on
Earth in other words even if a new kind
of Life did come into existence it's
extremely plausible I can't tell you it
absolutely happened but extremely
plausible to imagine that it just dies
out because it's being out competed by
the life that already exists you know
um living organisms need resources
energy and food and light and whatever
and the life that we have here on Earth
is really good at hoovering up those
resources so I would not expect that
even if life began again uh it would
flourish in any noticeable way
Joey asks has teaching philosophy
changed the way you view physics well
largely no I think because you know I
mean my teaching philosophy experience
is literally one course this semester my
thinking about philosophy and doing
philosophy over the last decade or so
has absolutely changed the way I view
physics I have a much clearer idea of a
lot of issues in the foundations of
physics I recently gave a talk at
Hopkins to the physics department on you
know why the foundations of physics is
interesting and I I shouldn't say this
out loud because I'll obligate myself to
do it but at some point I would like to
sort of do a video along those lines
trying to explain to people why there
are issues in the foundations of physics
that real physicists should be
interested in
um but I think that there are I think
that there are issues where physicists
are trained to get the right answer in
sometimes sloppy ways
and that is often fine but some cases it
is not fine it can lead you astray and I
think that that is there are places in
physics today where some more careful
philosophical kinds of reasoning would
be of use so in that extent yes I have
been changed
Kevin James says for all the people in
North America and Europe who are not in
favor of strong or any action on climate
change do you think they could be
convinced by considering the massive
number of migrants that will will be
created once the big middle of the world
becomes less hospitable due to worsening
weather events and less food security
after all where else will they have to
go
well if what you're asking me is as a
matter of empirical practical fact will
they be convinced by that no I think
they will not be convinced by that
because I think that anyone in the
modern world who pays any attention to
what is going on and is not in favor of
strong action on climate change is just
deeply living in denial right they're
clearly not wanting to accept that
conclusion and therefore they're not
gonna and therefore if you say well
here's another bad aspect of that
conclusion it's very easy for them to
still not accept that conclusion so I
think it's fine to emphasize these
problems I mean the problems are real
you should be honest about what they are
it's not a matter of scare mongering be
honest just say you know what is
actually likely to happen
um but again it's not like there's some
fact that we've not been telling people
that if we just share with them they
will all change their minds it's just
not that simple or that straightforward
Jordan Dansby says multiple Popular
Science media have asked their readers
and viewers to debate whether math is
invented or discovered the answer seems
obvious to me it is a human invention to
describe the world is this real a real
debate among professional philosophers
of science or relegated to the mass
consumption media yeah this is very much
a real debate in fact we have had here
on the podcast people with opposite
points of view about this uh Max tegmark
who is a physicist of course not a
philosopher but he is a champion of
thinking that mathematics is discovered
not invented that mathematics is a real
platonic existence out there in the
world and this is probably the majority
point of view among professional
mathematicians at least I'm not sure
what the majority point of view is among
professional physicists but it's not a
consensus point of view there's plenty
of people who disagree
so last year we began uh in January with
Jody izuni who is a philosopher who's a
champion of nominalism which says that
uh mathematics is invented it's a way of
talking about the world uh the world
exists but mathematics is a language we
use to describe it the word nominalism
comes from naming you know giving words
to things and so nominalism as opposed
to realism about mathematical truths but
it's very very much not completely uh
agreed upon so that's a that's a real
debate No Doubt
Joshua hillerope says are there any
non-physics or otherwise related to your
day jobs topics that you find really
interesting but don't think you would
interview someone about on mindscape
I try to think about this is a good
question
um you know there's two true things that
I can say one is that the overwhelming
Criterion for a mindscape episode is
that I am interested in it so I'm not
trying to be uniform or fair or
comprehensive in my coverage I try to do
things that I think are interesting
other people will think other things are
interesting and they will do their own
podcasts and that's great let a thousand
flowers bloom
um do are there other topics that I do
think are interesting and yet would not
do an episode about I mean there
probably are but they're more you know
practical or political or aesthetic
things you know like the kinds of
podcasts I listen to are not clones of
mindscape right like I like listen to
like comedians or uh crime podcasts or
something like that and on the on the
off chance that I had time to listen to
podcasts
um
or or political news podcasts right or
history podcasts or things like that but
I think these things are very valuable
and serve a purpose but they're a
different purpose than what we have here
at mindscape so I don't you know it will
occasionally happen that something that
we talk about here on mindscape overlaps
with a question of current political
interest but only as a side effect right
I want the questions we talk about here
to be more or less Universal to be still
interesting 100 years from now or at
least let's say 10 years from now
um so there's no like oh here's the
aftermath of the most recent election I
think that's really important and
interesting I think that politics is
important and it matters but if we're
talking about politics here on mindscape
we're probably talking about political
Theory and very very big picture
questions not why did this person do
better than another person in an
election
I have a rough guideline that I don't
want to have people who are currently in
political office on the podcast that's
not I you know I always violate my own
guidelines we did have Andrew Leon from
uh Australia he's in the Australian
Parliament but I think that politicians
you know have things they need to do
other than be Scholars and intellectuals
right so they're trying to get things
done in the real world which is good but
it's not what I want to talk about here
on the podcast
Elliot Specht says mindscape has had
many interesting episodes on subjects
which are right in your Corey area of
expertise like cosmology along with
equally interesting episodes and far-off
subjects like history and biology then
there is a gap few episodes have
discussed areas of physics which aren't
your specialty like condensed matter or
plasma is this because these fields are
less interesting or because they are
better covered by other podcasts
you know again I think that there's it's
a complicated list of things you know we
do not reveal a heroin mindscape the set
of people who I've invited on but didn't
come on okay
um but also I do think that there are
certain things that I will do a better
job talking about than other things so
perhaps they are better left talked
about by others we have had condensed
matter physicists on the podcast Monica
schleier Smith Nigel goldenfeld and
others but it's certainly not my
expertise and
I do think that you know I'm not trying
to be comprehensive I I never ever
promised that I will give Fair coverage
to every single field this is not meant
to be a judgment on the relative
interestingness or importance of
different fields this is uh a very
idiosyncratic personal decision on the
basis of me thinking the things you're
interesting me thinking that I can do a
job talking to someone and the someone
out there being willing to come on the
podcast so don't read too much into What
fields do and do not appear here on
mindscape Colleen Edwards says I'm new
here but have been a fan of your writing
in work for a while your book the big
picture was eloquently positive and
personally influential you mentioned at
the end of the book that he used to go
to church as a child and you also went
to Villanova University which I know is
a religious University I'm curious how
your own family and loved ones responded
to you going from a Believer to an
atheist and if you have any advice to
help those of us who are going through
through that now
well I you know giving advice like that
is very very difficult because it's
always true that everyone's individual
situation is different and that's
especially true for something like
talking to your family about your
religious beliefs you know um
my family was in some sense religious
but honestly not that religious it was
more of a social thing than a
deep-seated belief kind of thing they
were never fundamentalist or especially
devoted or anything like that and even
Villanova even though it was a Catholic
University wasn't all that demanding of
its students in terms of being religious
in fact there were zero demands in terms
of being religious the closest to a
demand was something like uh you had to
take religious studies courses there
were huge numbers of Demands of how many
courses you had to take but that's okay
I liked taking those courses they were
interesting you know the presence and
absence of God death and dying you know
these are kind of interesting topics
that I had fun learning about so
I never personally had any dramatic uh
phase transition in my beliefs or
confrontation with my family or anything
like that I know that other people are
in a very different situation where it's
very important to their families that
they have beliefs and that they want
everyone in the family to have a belief
so I'm not really in a good position to
offer advice based on experience about
how to deal with a situation like that
you know I think that it's important to
just emphasize to your family that you
should love each other in the family
regardless of your beliefs about the
fundamental nature of reality
how you are as a person is what matters
how you treat other people but that's
just what an atheist would say so you
know if they choose not to be convinced
by that and I don't know what to do my
only other marginally uh useful advice
might be to make sure you're talking to
other people who are on your side you
know who are not within your family and
who appreciate where you're coming from
but are not overly judging about your
family either you know your family
members are human beings they have their
own pluses and minuses in terms of uh
intellect and compassion and all those
things and
look there's a spectrum okay there are
people there are families that are super
duper religious but will nevertheless be
supportive in understanding of children
or whatever who become non-religious
there are other families that are that
are just terrible people and will you
know treat you badly because of your
personal religious beliefs and I think
that you should deal very differently
with those two circumstances so you know
hang in there there's plenty of people
in the world who are not religious and
plenty of people who have gone through
these experiences their whole
ex-evangelical communities or ex-mormon
communities or ex-muslim communities
like I said I never felt the need to
engage with them because my transition
as it were was extremely mild but uh if
something you're going through is more
difficult than that then that might be a
kind of set of people to reach out to
Jeffrey Siegel or Seagal says the talk
with Rafael buso was very interesting I
had not appreciated that even though
black holes have incredibly High entropy
the fact that they evaporate implies
that photons in empty space have even
higher entropy is that correct do we
have to go through black holes to get to
the highest entropy stage or could the
universe have gone from big bang
directly to photons in space actually is
photons in empty space even the highest
possible entropy state of the universe
or could the development of new
universes increase it even more
so there's a couple questions there
you're only supposed to ask one question
but sometimes I let people get away with
it
um yeah it is absolutely correct that
the state the black hole evaporates into
which is a set of photons and other
particles moving away from the black
hole in an increasingly dilute gas is
higher entropy than the black hole
itself is was and that makes sense you
could predict that because there's
something called the second law of
Thermodynamics it says B increases right
so this is completely compatible with
entropy increasing
there's no rule that says the universe
has to go through any particular State
black holes included to get to a higher
entropy State and the specific paths
that any physical system takes to go
from low entropy to high entropy can in
principle be very complex and hard to
predict and that's you know not
something that is subject to a simple
rule like entropy increases there's no
rule that says entropy increases as fast
as possible or in this particular way or
anything like that those rules are all
much more situation dependent and and
complicated as far as what the highest
entropy state is it is empty space it is
not a gas of photons because we live in
a world with gravity Einstein's general
relativity says that in a universe with
energy in it it's either going to be
expanding or Contracting our universe is
expanding
and that expansion relates to an
increase of entropy of the universe so
we're going to keep expanding and
emptying out until we are as empty as
can be in what we call decider space as
we've talked about before empty space
with a positive vacuum energy uh in fact
Aiden Chapman Davis who used to be a
grad student at Caltech and I wrote a
paper uh establishing this result using
previous results from Rafael buso and
Neda engelhardt to former mindscape
guests and so Aiden and I established
that this
fact that the Universe expands and
empties out can literally be thought of
as a manifestation of the second law of
Thermodynamics so and why you know what
is the entropy what are the degrees of
freedom there well I wish we knew better
than we did this comes into deep
questions about quantum gravity and how
to relate
cosmology and curvature of space-time to
more traditional thermodynamic Notions
which is something that we don't have a
really good handle on so I can't tell
you really more about that
Andrea esparini says priority question
could you explain why an Airborne
aircraft doesn't lose the rotational
velocity it had when in contact with the
ground I understand the atmosphere is
still rotating with the Earth but
somehow that doesn't sound fully
convincing
yeah I don't I'm not quite sure what the
lack of conviction here is
um if an object is in empty space it
maintains its velocity right the
velocity doesn't just get lost uh in
order to lose velocity you need to
somehow have friction or dissipation or
something like that of course the
atmosphere of the earth is moving with
the Earth
so if you have an airplane that is just
sitting stationary above the ground then
it will not lose any energy but of
course it has no velocity so we'll just
fall to the ground but real aircrafts
have engines propellers jet engines
whatever and they push them forward so
you're moving with respect to the motion
of the earth and the atmosphere you if
you're sitting stationary on the ground
you're really from the point of view of
the reference frame of the solar system
moving along with the surface of the
Earth and so is the atmosphere moving
along the surface of the Earth and
it's a little bit subtle because it's a
rotating reference frame and things like
that but those subtleties don't matter
the right way to think about it is
simply all of your emotions are with
respect to the Earth not with respect to
some absolute reference frame out there
in the universe because there is no such
thing and when you take off in an
airplane and the engine is pushing you
in some direction you're accelerating
with respect to the Earth and that's the
velocity that you continue to have
Richard says in the last year or so what
books did you read for the podcast that
you would not have ordinarily been
interested in Reading were there any
that particularly surprised you by being
more interesting than you thought they'd
be well you know again uh the people I
invite on the podcast are the ones whose
books I want to read you know no one's
forcing me to do this so there's really
no books out there that I would not have
been interested in Reading there's a lot
of books written by mindscape guests
that I might not have found the time to
read okay uh so therefore that's why I
have them on the podcast both to talk to
them and to nudge me to reading as much
of the book as I can
so really the question would be whose
books are even more interesting than I
thought they would be and I I always
hesitate to answer questions like this
because I think it's super duper unfair
to all the people who I'm not gonna
mention you know again the the people
who appear on the podcast I'm enormously
grateful for they're busy people they
take time out of their day to share some
of these thoughts widely and I don't
want to rank previous podcasts or
anything like that but you know if I
were forced to which I'm not this is not
a priority question but okay I'll
pretend I'm being forced here um
again there's a lot and they're very
different Camilla pang's book uh the
instruction manual for being humans
written by someone on the autism
spectrum was fascinating and very
educational uh Nick Lane's book on
mitochondria of all things and the Krebs
cycle uh Elizabeth Cohen's book on the
political value of time these are all
you know really just interesting books
that I are all very much in my
wheelhouse for being interested
interested in
um I'll also mention especially Brad the
Long's book on the economic history of
the long 20th century again something I
am interested in but
bread is an even better writer than I
thought he would be and you know his
discursive style uh which is a pleasure
to listen to although it makes it hard
to sort of get through as much stuff as
you might want to get through in the
course of the podcast but it makes for
great writing because like he
illuminates all these points with these
wonderful examples and it turns out to
be a giant book uh a massive Tome but
well worth diving into if uh you haven't
already read that one
cybak says I had the heartbreaking
experience of falling in love with one
of my closest friends who does not share
the sentiment assuming many worlds is
correct do you think there could be a
real world out there where she and I are
living happily ever after together
well I'll give you the honest answer
that I always give to questions like
this which is no there is not a world
where she and you are living happily
ever after there might be a world out
there where other people who are kind of
like you and her are living happily ever
after together but they're not you and
they're not her you're not the same
person as copies of yourself that come
through different Quantum histories
living in other worlds you're you here
on this Earth and that's the right way
to conceptualize who you are uh I I feel
bad I'm sorry that you had this
heartbreaking experience this is uh one
that often happens but you know in the
end it's easy for me to say but you're
going to be way way better off falling
in love with people who do share the
sentiment and uh chances are good that
if you keep looking around that will
eventually happen you know so don't let
one such event like this get you down
it's uh keeping you open for something
much better to happen down the road
John Welborn says
when it comes to studying science
including physics in space is there an
end game you can imagine that makes this
Pursuit worth the time money energy
spent or do you not look at it in those
terms I understand the way we may
discover things along the way that can
help us here on Earth but is there a
purpose beyond that if so what is it why
should we pursue anything more in life
than making sure the people on Earth are
safe healthy and happy
well what I would answer in response is
why should we even pursue that
who says that we should pursue making
people safe healthy and happy not that
I'm against doing that I'm in favor of
doing that but why do you want to do
that I mean be serious about it think
about what the motivation is what is
your philosophical justification for
saying that that particular Pursuit is
worthwhile and I think that there's
plausible answers to that but it's
non-trivial to think about what they are
and how best to put them I don't think
the purposes in life are given to us
from outside much like morality I don't
think it's objectively out there in the
world
I talk about this at some length in the
big picture if you want to read more
about it I think that purposes are
constructed by human beings and we base
our construction to purpose on
pre-existing inclinations and intuitions
and passions that we have within
ourselves in the case of doing science
those inclinations come from Curiosity a
desire to better understand our world
some of that is very down to earth and
survival driven right the better picture
we have of the world the better we're
going to do it living within it but some
of it is a little bit more lofty than
that you know evolution is not very good
at fine-tuning our existence and
abilities as living beings to
down-to-earth survival mechanisms you
know it does that but there's all these
spin-offs all these extra things the
same capacities that help us as human
beings conceptualize the world for
purposes of survival and flourishing and
reproduction go go beyond those I want
to understand the world I am curious
about it that's why it's worth spending
because I want it that's why it's worth
spending time on this and that leaves
completely open the idea that other
people might not find it worthwhile and
that's fine I don't judge them to be
faulty because they don't share the same
drives and desires and intuitions as I
have and it's completely compatible in
my mind to want to understand the world
better and to make people on earth safe
healthy and happy maybe not to be too
insinuating about it but maybe
understanding the world better helps us
make people safe healthy and happy
Jim Murphy says I'm curious what it's
like to be a public personality as well
as a professor do you have any Star
Struck students do other professors
treat you differently
uh short answer is no I don't have any
Star Trek struck students and the other
professors don't treat me differently
you know
um there's different levels of being a
public personality right like I'm not
the level of uh I don't know Dolly
Parton or someone like that right I can
easily walk down the street without
being recognized of course to people who
listen to the mindscape podcast they are
used to hearing my voice but most of my
students and very few of my colleagues
are mindscape listeners I did have you
know one student recently come up to me
and say like hey yeah like I was
listening to someone else's podcast and
your name came up and you know I forgot
like you're famous I think that you're
just like my professor and I think
that's basically what people have as the
attitude you know the number of
landscape listeners sadly still very
tiny compared to the number of people in
the world or even the number of people
who buy my books or Etc so no not a lot
of uh celebrity treatment just uh within
the academic environment
T.O Alexander says let's assume pan
psychism or pan experientialism is the
case and for the sake of argument let's
also assume that it is an emerging
phenomenon but at a very fundamental
level not as fundamental as an electron
or proton but still quite small and
ubiquitous
wouldn't that then necessitate the
constant collapsing of wave functions at
every point where the Consciousness
particles exist follow-up could that be
one possible explanation for why all of
us macroscopic humans more or less
experience the same universe
so I'm not at all sure that the
assumptions of the question fit together
nicely if you're literally pan psychist
or pan experientialist then I don't
think you can say it's an emerging
phenomenon I think that the whole idea
of pan psychism is to say that
Consciousness is absolutely fundamental
So when you say pan psychism but not
emergent or only emergent not
fundamental non-existing electrons and
protons I don't know what that means or
how that would work to the other part of
the question
I don't know what the answer to that one
is either but here it's it's facing the
very real issues that all of these kinds
of proposals face when they try to
reconcile themselves with reality that
you can't just like add things like
Consciousness or Minds to the laws of
physics and not have serious
consequences there what do you mean by
Consciousness particles are there
Consciousness degrees of freedom like
you know can you have Consciousness
decoherence I don't know the answer to
those questions I suspect there are no
answers to those questions because all
of these ideas are fundamentally
ill-defined they're just not that
specific enough to provide answers and
if they were they would probably be
ruled out by experiment so in in terms
of could this be an explanation for why
we all experience the same universe no
you don't need an explanation for that
the re the explanation for that is that
there is a universe and we're in it
that's the explanation
bits plus atoms says when I came across
a passage about conservation of
information while reading the biggest
ideas I wondered what symmetry is
associated with this conserved quantity
I understand nerder's Theory to be for
each symmetry of the lagrangian there is
a conserved quantity does information
fit into this framework
um I think the answer is no it doesn't
because you're pointing out something
that is very true about nerder's theorem
for each symmetry of the lagrangian
there is a conserved quantity it's not
the other way around it's not true that
for everything conserved there must be a
symmetry the fact that information is
conserved is a basic feature of the
setup that has lagrandians in it in the
first place you know informations would
be conserved even if there was not a
symmetry of the lagrant gene as long as
you have a lagrangian this is a
particular way of formulating dynamical
laws of physics information will be
conserved there's other
non-lagrangian-based laws of physics
where information is not conserved but
our universe at least for we many worlds
people the lagrangian picture seems to
be pretty good and therefore information
does be concerned seem to be conserved
in the wave function of the universe
Michael ayling says to explain the
uniformity of the CMB has anyone
proposed an alternative to thermal
equilibrium could some other physical
process have led to it all being the
same temperature in expanding Universe
without the need for inflation
so you have to be careful here because
of course thermal equilibrium does not
explain the uniformity of the CMV
we live in a universe with gravity and a
universe with gravity thermal
equilibrium does not look smooth you get
lumpy regions with black holes empty
regions elsewhere so the CMB is smooth
and the temperature Spectrum the
spectrum of the radiation is that of a
black body in equilibrium but it's it's
the spectrum of an object in equilibrium
without gravity
but it is not an object without gravity
that's the mystery why does it have that
particular Spectrum even though it is
not that kind of thing so inflation
provides one way to do that a way for
the matter degrees of freedom to
thermalize even though the gravitational
configuration of matter is very very
much out of equilibrium are there other
ways to do it other than inflation well
the only real good way of doing it other
than inflation is just deposit that this
is some kind of initial condition right
maybe the wave function of the universe
just is that way or maybe God just made
it that way that's not to say there's
not some other theory that is not
inflation that will be good but we
haven't come up with it yet
Ed says in the Futurama episode Crimes
of the hot the problem of global warming
is solved by moving the Earth farther
from the Sun leaving aside the
engineering challenges of such a course
do you have an opinion or comment on the
long-term possibility of controlling the
Earth's temperature by adjusting the
Earth's orbit as a bonus question do you
think it'll be easier to physically move
the entire Earth or to fix global
capitalism such that carbon emissions
can be reduced quickly so yeah I think
it's easier to fix global capitalism
the idea of moving the Earth physically
farther from the Sun is very very very
very far away from being practically
feasible it is much much easier to
imagine fixing the Earth's atmosphere
one way or the other even if you go to
very science fictiony scenarios like
inventing little microorganisms that
will eat all of the greenhouse gases Etc
that's not completely science fictional
maybe we'll be able to do that someday
maybe we'll able to
Geo engineer or that's not really the
right way to do it right terraform the
Earth itself okay
that's very very difficult still way
easier than moving the Earth around its
orbit fixing capitalism is actually even
easier than that is it easy no but you
have to be a little bit realistic about
these uh the different levels of
complexity involved here you know at
least if nothing else it's a good
reminder of how difficult it would be to
terraform another planet like Mars or
Venus or whatever we can't even get our
act together to fix the Earth's
atmosphere even though it's already
pretty good we're just breaking it we
can't prevent ourselves from breaking it
just imagine how difficult it would be
to completely alter a whole other
planet's atmosphere
Benjamin barbrel says priority question
do all of the branches in many worlds
Multiverse look like our own familiar
Universe homogeneous at large scales Etc
or would some of them appear somewhat
exotic to our eyes is our Branch typical
if that means anything
well again we don't know like we can't
visit these other universes but it is
completely plausible that other branches
look very very different
um you would like to think that our
branch is typical in some sense but this
is just yeah maybe I even shouldn't it
is a priority question so I have to
answer it but my answer is we don't know
nearly enough about the wave function of
the overall Universe including other
branches of the wave function to answer
a question like this I'm not sure
whether we ever will but we can ask it
we can think about it I just don't have
any uh informed basis for speculation
Danny avidan says would you mind sharing
your thoughts about morality and meat
eating I don't mean it antagonistically
it's just that as a public intellectual
and a figure of high moral intellectual
standing I wanted to hear your thoughts
on the matter especially given your love
of cats of course we all fall short of
our moral aspirations and contain
contradictions but how does a cow or Pig
fall short of the confines of your
circle of empathy if a similar mammal
doesn't
so I I have talked about this before so
I can just say I mean Danny you might
not have heard it but I'll try to put it
um as as clearly as possible
um I'm not sure what the love of cats
has to do with it you know I don't have
any moral objection against other people
eating cats I don't want them to eat my
cats I will prevent that from happening
because I have bonded with my cats but I
do think that human beings are different
than other kinds of animals including
mammals I'm very open to the idea that
there are other species that are not
human and yet nevertheless should be
protected and not eaten uh but I don't
think that cows and pigs or or even cats
and dogs fall into those categories and
my reasoning is that I don't attach any
metaphysical essence of worthiness to
lives I'm a pragmatist about this I
think that uh I don't like it when
people or or even animals suffer or have
pain and so I don't want any animals to
needlessly suffer whether or not they're
used for food or not that is definitely
a place where I guess if you want to
talk about it in terms of a circle of
empathy
um I'm very empathetic about those kinds
of things but
I think there's an important difference
between human beings and cows about how
we live in the world and how we
conceptualize death I don't think that
cows really have a picture of what it
would like to not be not existing you
know the to visualize hypothetical
counterfactual Futures in which they
have died and to fret about them and I
think that the relationship of human
beings with respect to past present and
future is different than those in other
animals and we've talked about this on
the podcast before we'll talk about it
again uh but I think that's a crucial
difference and I I think that that sort
of ability to fear death to fear not not
just you know to to instinctively fear
that you're in danger which certainly
cows can do and other animals can do but
to mentally visualize the hypothetical
Prospect of being in danger just for
sort of abstract
intellectual reasons like if someone
tells you using words that they're going
to kill you okay or that you're in
danger of Dying For Something you are
afraid already right just because of
words entering your ears and listening
to them and that's the kind of thing
that other animals just don't have they
don't have that capacity
to abstractly reason about the future in
the same way to me that's a difference
you know there's no intrinsic value to
life all lives end we live in a world
where lives are finite my life will end
Ariel and caliban's lives will end Ariel
and caliban by the way certainly not
vegetarians they they have no problem at
all cycle of Life they will eat they
will be predators and and they will eat
other animals with no qualms and that
happens in the world and yeah I don't
think that you can sort of object to
that reality
you can try to make a world in which
there is less suffering and there is
less needless pain and that is a world
that I am in favor of trying to make
Justin Wolcott says in the big picture
you say we can't pick out one moment or
a particular aspect of any one moment
and identify it as the cause different
moments in time in the history of the
universe follow each other According to
some pattern but no one moment causes
any other and then Justin says I'm
trying to understand why it is illegal
to say the cat caused the ball to fall
on the floor but legal to say the ball
is on the floor because of the prior
state of the universe plus the laws of
physics is there any way to restate this
in a way that involves a cat so
I'm trying to understand why you are
asking this question because uh I would
never say it is illegal to say the cat
calls the ball to fall on the floor and
I would never I would not emphasize that
you should instead say the ball's on the
floor because of the prior state of the
universe plus the laws of physics
um what I was saying in the quote is you
cannot pick out one moment including the
prior state of the universe and identify
it as the cause the important thing here
is that there is a crucial difference
between the fundamental laws of physics
and the emergent higher level
description that we use to go through
our everyday lives at the fundamental
level
there are patterns there are laws of
physics that relate this the
configuration of the Universe At One
Moment In Time to the configuration at
other moments in time it is not useful
to think about those patterns as a
series of cause and effect relations at
the fundamental level rather think about
them as the laws of physics that's what
they are whether it's the Schrodinger
equation or f equals m a or whatever a
web of cause and effect relationships
becomes a relevant and important way to
think about the universe at the higher
immersion level
precisely when you have cats and balls
falling on the floor it makes a hundred
percent sense to say the cat caused the
ball to fall on the floor it does not
make sense to say that is a deep down
feature of the fundamental nature of
reality it is an emergent higher level
description because we live in a world
with macro States and an arrow of time
from which you can sensibly expose facto
Define cause and really cause and effect
relationships
Felix dare asks a priority question
since reading your book I'm left with
the inescapable idea that for each
decision I make there is another
Universe identical to this one up until
that point but in which I took the other
decision my understanding if the
Multiverse theory is correct is that
this is happening constantly driven by
ongoing Quantum level events in my brain
such that there is a different Universe
with a different version of me for every
possible decision that I ever could have
taken I'm struggling to reconcile this
with any meaningful sense of agency or
free will so be grateful to any
explanation as to what I have got wrong
so there's two things to say about this
one is
I I I
tried in the book to very carefully
separate the idea of branches of the
wave function coming into existence from
the idea of human beings making
decisions human beings making decisions
do not cause different universes to come
into existence now if you're trying to
be careful about it which I was trying
to be you might say that different
quantum mechanical processes that do
cause different universes to come into
existence might be interpreted at the
macroscopic level as human beings making
decisions okay so I'm not sure whether
that distinction came through in your
reading but I hope to emphasize it here
as far as free will is concerned there
is literally no difference in the
discussion of Free Will between this
kind of universe with a deterministic
equation like the Schrodinger equation
and many worlds versus a classical
Universe with a deterministic equation
like Newton's equation in both equations
in both universes you follow the laws of
physics that's what you do whether or
not you would like to speak about those
universes in terms of Free Will has
nothing to do with the nature of the
fundamental laws of physics what it has
to do with is is there a notion of free
will that is useful to us that is
compatible with us being physical
systems following the fundamental laws
of physics I think there is I do not
talk about that a great detail in
something deeply hidden the book that
you're talking about but I do talk about
it in some detail in the big picture and
elsewhere we talked about it here on the
podcast with Janan Ismail and other
people
this is called compatibilism Free Will
has nothing to do with the fundamental
laws of physics it has to do with how we
talk about human beings at the higher
emergent level and therefore is
completely compatible with whatever the
fundamental laws of physics have to be
happen to be
Tim gionitos says you mentioned in
another podcast that there is a theorem
which seems to indicate that if the
hidden variable interpretation of
quantum mechanics is true any prediction
it comes up with will always be the same
as in the many worlds interpretation
however you were skeptical of this
implication of the theorem was true have
you found a resolution to this since
making that statement uh no I've not I
don't suspect to do so anytime soon
that's just something that is
percolating in the back of my mind not
something that I am putting a lot of
effort into at the present moment just
to fill out what is going on here
um in bohomian mechanics which is one
particular version of hidden variable
theories aka the pilot wave theory there
is a notion called equivariance so you
have both the wave function and you have
variables that represent the positions
of particles or what have you and the
equivariance idea says that if you start
the distribution of particle positions
in a random selection
that follows the probability
distribution given by the wave function
squared then it will continue to follow
the distribution given by the wave
function squared so there's an extra big
leap you need to make in these hidden
variable theories that the extra
variables that you've invented line up
with the born rule of quantum mechanics
that you can prove that or you can claim
to prove that if they do initially line
up they stay lining up and then there's
arguments that maybe even if they don't
they will evolve into that but those
arguments are a lot more dicey but so I
would like to better understand both uh
the equilibration aspect as opposed to
equivariance which is if you start out
of that distribution do you truly evolve
to it
I worry about how that fits in with
leoville's theorem or something like
that but it's not classical mechanics so
you can't just invoke Louisville's
theorem in a in a simple way
um
but the other is you know any theorem
always involves assumptions and famously
in physics there's a whole bunch of
theorems that have turned out to be
irrelevant because the assumptions
behind them are not physically true so I
just don't know exactly what the
assumptions of this theorem are or
whether or not you can wriggle out of
them in some other situation or whatever
I'm curious about it but I just don't
know probably not but I'm just curious
OA owe says I've recently been reading
general relativity for babies to my 16
month old son
I don't think he gets it but maybe in
time one of one page talks about how a
spinning Mass drags space with it
similar to how rest Mass warps
space-time I believe that an object
spinning in space will continue to spin
indefinitely absent and external force
due to angular momentum being conserved
yet changes to space-time require energy
to create how can a spinning Mass drag
space time without expending energy to
do so
yeah this is a very good question and
perhaps disappointingly the answer is
that the word drag is not really
completely appropriate here
um you're almost you've almost put your
finger on the right answer here uh it is
similar to how a rest Mass warps
space-time so if you have a mass at rest
that is not rotating it will have around
it a gravitational field a warping of
the geometry of space-time
and if the mass is just sitting there
not doing anything
the warping of space-time around it will
also sit there and not do anything it
will be static now if the object is
rotating then the configuration of
space-time around it will also bend in a
way that is related to that rotation but
it doesn't get dragged in the sense that
there is some force that is dragging it
back okay it's not really like friction
on a floor or something like that the
statement is simply that the static
Eternal configuration of the space time
reflects the angular momentum of the
body in it that is spinning there's no
energy being transferred from the
spinning Mass to space-time it's just
that the solution to Einstein's equation
for the spinning metric
has a fixed angular momentum and that's
it so your intuition is correct but this
is precisely a case where the attempt to
translate things into the English
language has led your intuition astray
David Dubrow says is the concept of weak
emergence related to entropy in this way
or am I missing something both seem to
be a way of measuring our lack of
complete information about the structure
and dynamics of entities at lower levels
when observed from higher levels entropy
seems to be measuring our inability to
detect the difference in microstates
when observed from a macro point of view
emergence seems to be a way of
characterizing the exact same thing as
far as I'm seeing namely that there are
larger patterns composed of lower level
entities and we don't need to know the
exact happenings of the lower levels to
see the patterns at the higher levels
well they're not I mean they're related
but they're not the same thing so
they're both related to the fact that in
the world in which we live there are
macro States so I would say in some
sense emergence is prior to entropy
because the reason why entropy is a
useful interesting concept is because we
can take a system that is made of many
microscopic constituents and coarse
grain it into macro States made of
potentially many different possible
microstates corresponding to the same
macro state so that is a feature of
emergence and then we use that feature
to Define entropy in the emergent higher
level description where you have the
macro States the entropy is the
logarithm of the number of microstates
that would have looked like that macro
state but the point of it is a little
bit different right emergence is useful
when we can take those coarse grained
macroscopic descriptions and from them
make a theory from use those macro
descriptions and observable macroscopic
properties to predict what will happen
next to get some handle on how the
universe behaves even in the absence of
the microscopic information whereas the
entropy is keeping track of you know
something more thermodynamic it's again
it's very closely related but as you
know the origin of entropy was from
thermodynamics in the 19th century where
entropy was reflecting the fact that
certain processes happen in One
Direction of time and not in the other
direction of time so you could have
emergence even without that right with
the earth going around the Sun being
followed by just its Center of mass
position and momentum is an example of
emergence you don't need to keep track
of all the microscopic atoms and
molecules in the earth to keep track of
its motion around the Sun but no entropy
is being generated or anything like that
so I would say that entropy is a special
case of the usefulness of coarse
graining and emergence
Douglas De Young says is the concept of
true Randomness sensical it seems like
something from nothing or information
from nowhere I appreciate that many
worlds avoids the random outcomes of
measurement by positing a larger
deterministic possibility space
to give you a definitive answer here it
depends on what you mean by true
Randomness uh there's different kinds of
Randomness and there's different kinds
of Truth so the way that we usually talk
about it in philosophy of science is is
probability objective or subjective in
other words is there some sense in which
when you say that something is a
probability of happening you're really
just reflecting the fact that there's
something that will definitely happen
but you just don't know right it's your
knowledge your epistemic state in which
case you would classify that probably
probability notion as being subjective
at the bottom level because it's
relative to your knowledge versus
there's no possible thing you could know
and yet there is a that would prevent
this from being a probability okay a
true objective chance and you might say
that in objective collapse models of
quantum mechanics there is just a true
objective probability there
even there I'm much more of a
subjectivist about probability myself I
think that if they're if it is true that
in the fundamental laws of physics I
don't think this is true but if it were
true that given the complete state of
the universe now we could not
deterministically say what the future
holds but we could say uh on the basis
of past frequencies that there is a
probability of something happening this
way versus that way I would still want
to say that's not an objective
probability that's just something we
don't know namely the future of the
universe
so this goes hand in hand with me being
an eternalist about time if you think
that what exists is all moments of time
but you just don't know what is going to
happen in the future then you can be
someone who believes in truly stochastic
laws of physics but still treats
probability as fundamentally subjective
if you're a presentist about time and
you think that the fundamental laws of
physics are stochastic or chancy then
you're going to be more likely to be an
objectivist about probability
Kevin O'Toole says in the October AMA
you said there was no experiment you can
do to prove the past hypothesis however
it seems that any Universe where the
laws of thermodynamics are true and the
past hypothesis is false should make
some very strong very falsifiable
predictions the theory in that Universe
would say that with overwhelming
probability our experiences are
explained by a small world fluctuating
from equilibrium and by illusory stuff
outside that world just enough to make
us think that the universe is bigger and
explain what we've observed so far all
that's true but it does not get you the
result Kevin that you want to get
because you have to distinguish between
asking given this
Universe in other words a universe where
there really just are random
fluctuations and we don't have the past
hypothesis what would you expect to see
next that is a question you can ask and
that is what you're talking about but
the theory Choice question
about doing an experiment to prove the
past hypothesis is not that question
that's just calculating the likelihood
function right in Bayes theorem to
choose between the theories you have to
multiply that likelihood function by the
prior so the question is not given this
Theory what do you expect to see next
but given what you see what is the most
likely Theory okay and given a universe
that is randomly fluctuating it is true
that given what we see now the next
thing we should see is just some thermal
equilibrium random fluctuations but
given that the next thing we see is not
thermal equilibrium random fluctuations
if that Universe were real it would
still be overwhelmingly likely that all
that stuff had just fluctuated into
existence okay so that's why you need to
assume the past hypothesis you can't
actually be a good Bayesian and Rule It
Out by data because under that set of
assumptions that all configurations of
stuff in the universe are equally likely
the prior probability that you're seeing
things randomly fluctuate into existence
is so overwhelmingly large that you
can't beat it down just by likelihood
functions and collecting new data
Brent Meeker says you've written a paper
with Jackie laudman about violation of
conservation laws and Quantum
measurements you said that energy was
only conserved on average but not in a
single measurement if I understood it
correctly it would also imply apply to
the measurement of any conserved
quantity Not Just Energy does this
provide any tests of many worlds versus
a cubism or the transactional
interpretation do all interpretations of
quantum mechanics imply non-conservation
in measurements so a couple of
clarifications here I did write such a
paper we did not say that energy is
conserved on average energy is not
conserved on average uh it fluctuates up
and down but it fluctuates up and down
by sizes that will generally decrease
with time the fluctuations in energy go
down over time so that by now in the
late Universe energy looks pretty darn
conserved to us
it you might think that this should
apply to the measurement of any
conserved quantity but there is a
loophole there you can be in a universe
that is that has a definite value of
other conserved quantities that has a
definite value of momentum or angular
momentum or electrical charge or
whatever and in that case there are zero
fluctuations whatsoever why can't you be
in a universe with a definite value of
energy because energy is special in
quantum mechanics energy is the thing
that tells you how the wave function
evolves with time remember the
Schrodinger equation says the
hamiltonian operates on the wave
function to tell you the time derivative
of the wave function the hamiltonian is
just the energy
so if you are in a state with definite
well-defined energy and nothing ever
changes literally nothing happens in
such a universe
this is a subtle and tricky set of
issues that people debate about but that
is the basic reason why we don't want to
say that we live in a universe that has
a definite energy we have an average
value of energy an expectation value at
least that's the way you would talk in
many worlds so when you compare many
worlds to other uh versions of the story
there's the shortcut is to say that in
any theory of quantum mechanics where
the energy of a Quantum state is well
defined
as the expectation value the hamiltonian
in that state then energy is not
conserved whether it's MWI or anything
else
there are other formulations of quantum
mechanics in something like cubism
you don't even say that there the
quantum state is not physical it's just
a state of your brain right so you don't
assign an energy to that thing therefore
there's nothing there to be conserved
likewise in Hidden variable theories
you might want to talk about what the
other variables are doing when you talk
about the energy but you don't know what
the other variables are so you just
never know what the energy is so that's
why it's a tricky fun thing and I hope
that other people dive into this in
their own favorite interpretations of
quantum mechanics
qubit says leoville's theorem tells us
that for a classical hamiltonian system
the phase Space volume stays constant
how is that possible for a chaotic
system where neighboring trajectories
move away from each other exponentially
well I mean there's there's two aspects
here one is that uh you have some area
or some volume in Phase space and in a
chaotic system usually the its volume
does stay constant that is what the
theorem tells you but it gets stretched
and pulled into Taffy with you know long
little tendrils while keeping the
overall volume constant
why can that happen uh in yet it's hard
to visualize it well it's because phase
space has a much higher dimensionality
than you can visualize very well so I
know what you're thinking you're
thinking of something that is just
two-dimensional phase space and it's
hard to get a two-dimensional phase
space with truly chaotic Dynamics to it
you usually have a bigger phase space
than that and so in the real world in a
higher dimensional phase space that
original blob of volume in Phase space
will be distorted but its volume will
stay constant even if the system is
chaotic
Moshe fader says with a World Cup in
progress I'm curious how you as a fan of
basketball a game with lots of scoring
feel about soccer a game with very
little scoring personally I think soccer
is a very poorly designed sport that is
only so globally popular because it's so
much more fun to play than it is to
watch do you agree that soccer could be
improved to be more entertaining and if
so what changes would you suggest
you know I'm a pluralist about
appreciating Sports I think that there's
different ways to appreciate Sports
one of the reasons why I like basketball
is because there is a lot of scoring not
because scoring is in intrinsically
exciting although that is arguably true
but because I think it's sort of
averages out over fluctuations right
over the course of a basketball game you
can always hit a lucky shot here or
there but the chances that single lucky
shot will be decisive are very small
because there's an integrated effect of
the whole effort that both teams are
putting in over time
whereas in not just soccer but any other
sport where the number of scores per
game is much lower random fluctuations
will generally play a much larger role
uh not they're not definitive they're
not you know the whole story by any
stretch but they will be more important
than in a game where you have lots of
chances to average over those
fluctuations but I get it if people like
to see the chess match right of teams
sort of fighting for every little
advantage in able to be in order to be
able to score it all right you can
easily say that you like the fact that
scoring is precious I don't I'm not
gonna say that people are wrong to like
that these are like whatever Sports you
like having said that
there is one way in which
um soccer or football as they call in
the rest of the world could obviously be
improved in the World Cup which is those
penalty kick shootouts at the end those
are terrible that is absolutely just
saying okay we're gonna flip a coin and
you can do better than that you can do I
haven't watched the World Cup this year
maybe they haven't been doing better
than that this year I'm not sure but
I've always that's always annoyed me by
the World Cup which otherwise I quite
enjoy
symbols asks do you get any sense that
life as in the origin of life is or was
inevitable
well no I get no such sense my sense is
that life uh was hard to get started
otherwise it would be much more
ubiquitous in the universe around us but
guess what nobody cares about my
personal sense I think that these are
issues where our data is very very very
meager and we can have Impressions or
guesses or priors but we shouldn't be
too wedded to them we'll be able to
collect a lot better data going forward
Stuart Hayne says I have a question
about the cosmic microwave background
when I think of a supernova I think of a
flash of light being emitted and then
traveling past us if we're not looking
we may not see it however the CMB
appears to be ever present even though
it originated from the surface of less
scattering is that because the CMB have
used all of space and was moving in all
directions and therefore it will be ever
present
yes this is the kind of question I like
in the amas the answer is yes you ask
the question and you also answered it we
talk about the surface of last
scattering but it's better to think
about a moment of last scattering
throughout all the universe you know
think of the early Universe it's more or
less homogeneous more or less the same
everywhere it's evolving in time because
space is expanding and things matter is
diluting away cooling off and at some
moment things recombine the electrons
come back with the protons you get atoms
that's what we call the moment of less
scattering the surface of last
scattering is just the intersection of
that moment with our personal past light
cone and as time goes on for us our
light cone moves out just a little bit
so as we look at the microwave
background from moment to moment we're
not looking at the same place in the
microwave background it looks like the
same place because the micro background
is very very smooth but if you look at
the micro background once and then a
year later
the photons that you see came from one
light year further away okay that's
almost no difference as far as the CMB
is concerned so it looks more or less
static and fixed but in fact you're
looking in slightly different places
Rob patro says the recent drama
surrounding Twitter has renewed debate
over the optimal bounds of speech on
online platforms as someone who seems
deeply dedicated to debate and Free
Speech but also cognizant of the
shortcomings of absolutism and aware of
the importance of practical Solutions
I'm curious about your thoughts on this
topic how do you think that we as a
society should balance the necessity of
open and free debate with the dangers
posed by speech that incites violence
and constitutes harassment particularly
in the context of private platforms like
Twitter that start to border the space
of a public utility
you know I don't think I can give an
answer that is any better than all the
implications here in the question that
Rob asked I think that uh there is a lot
of drama surrounding Twitter uh I'm
contemplating just you know decreasing
my use of Twitter honestly Twitter has
been great to me and I I get a lot of
value out of it but uh both with Elon
Musk buying it and you know letting a
lot of uh more disreputable people back
onto the platform and generally lowering
the tone overall plus the fact that
everyone else is just talking about
drama on Twitter rather than talking
about substantive things it's become
less enjoyable for me to go on there and
so I don't know what I will do I mean
I'm still there and I might just stay
there or I might leave or I really don't
know
um
I think there's a lot of interesting
questions here everyone knows everyone
who's thought about these in in detail
and with care knows that you have to
moderate uh social media you can't just
let everyone Yap out whatever they want
or if you do that's fine but no one is
going to join you because there's a lot
of hate-filled terrible voices out there
and who no one wants to listen to so
moderation is important and necessary if
only to obey the law but also just to
create a space that is pleasant and
people want to be in you can't just let
anyone say anything they want that is no
way to run a social media Network
you see that with Elon Musk inviting a
bunch of people on and then kicking them
back off again or changing a rule and
then changing it back again uh there are
reasons why these rules are there what
should the rules be you know I think
that's an honest difficult question I
would like ideally in the Utopia we
would have different social media
platforms that maybe could even talk to
each other but people would have an
ability to choose what kind of content
they were exposed to so people could in
some sense choose among a menu of
possible moderation strategies or
something like that but you have to do
some moderation you have to balance
different considerations you have to
balance the considerations of open and
free debate with considerations of
peaceful coexistence and harassment in
various kinds of things
now the very end of the question becomes
super interesting and difficult where
Rob brings up the idea that Twitter
starts to border the space of a public
utility I mean Twitter is a private
company and to some extent let the
private company do whatever it wants as
long as it's not actively harming other
people
but if it does become almost like a
monopoly or a special shared public
space then is there a motivation for
government to become involved and to
curate it or to regulate it
you know I kind of would want to keep
that to a minimum because you know we've
seen in in history that cyberspace the
internet moves very quickly
it wasn't that long ago in my lifetime
anyway people thought that Microsoft and
Microsoft Explorer were a monopoly on
the internet and that didn't last very
long right I think Twitter could easily
go away you know I don't think that
Twitter is in any sense necessary so
Twitter could just die in fact might be
dying in front of our eyes right now I
don't know maybe it's not again I hope
it's not I would much rather live in a
world where Twitter we're flourishing
and pleasant to be on
um but it could go away it could be
replaced by something else you know look
if someone if Google came along and just
did more or less exactly a clone of
Twitter with more or less reasonable
content moderation and an edit button
everyone would move there you know I
don't see why I mean it is hard to do of
course there's enormous infrastructure
and things like that that's why I said
Google rather than someone in there in
their garage but there's no
inevitability to these giant uh social
media platforms they're
assets
are rather intangible right the asset of
Twitter is the user base it's not some
Factory or something like this
um this is what we talked about with
John quagan when we talk about interest
rates and the sort of new disconnect
between interest rates and Company
valuations because
Twitter is the people and the people
could easily move tomorrow so Twitter
better get its acting gear otherwise
everyone will just go somewhere else
that's why I don't want government to
regulate it too much because it's not
inevitable if it becomes inevitable if
it becomes something as necessary and
important and unique as roads or Airways
or uh electromagnetic radio frequencies
then maybe there should be more
government intervention
Bert Rich says when it comes to the
great filter scenarios like climate
change Wars and pandemics are being
discussed but my personal candidate is
missing a failed physics experiment may
be always the same one for example some
new particle being created that results
in a cascading all planetary matter
pulverizing effect as an Insider is this
completely out of the question or
something that keeps you up at night
most other scenarios are in my opinion
too slow and not devastating enough I'm
confident that we could fix or survive
as a technological species just about
all of them
so look I've said it before my very
straightforward solution to the great
filter is that technological
civilizations are just super duper rare
either because life is rare or because
complex eukaryotic slash multicellular
life is super duper rare because because
you're right most of these other
um things about climate change Wars
pandemics or whatever maybe they'll
happen some of the time but they're not
inevitable uh if this happens thousands
of times or millions of times across the
Galaxy but maybe life just never forms
or evolved life super Advanced life
never forms that's much easier to
believe
as far as the new particle being created
there's a very strong argument against
that possibility namely that everything
we do here on Earth is done at much
higher energies and much more often out
there in the universe high energy cosmic
rays bump into each other bump into the
Earth uh they do all the physical
processes that we try to reproduce with
all of our particle accelerators Etc
here on Earth
people can and have
tried to wriggle out of those of that
very strong bound on what can possibly
happen to try to like cleverly invent
some scenario where something could
uniquely happen in a particle
accelerator but the the smart money is
that's just not going to happen so that
is not something that keeps me up at
night or does it keep up as far as I
know any other particle physicist that I
know about
Kevin says the political climate in the
U.S has grown increasingly tense and
partisan in recent years with several
unprecedented events occurring Roe v
Wade overturning January 6 riots Etc
what is it about our current time that
is causing such a tense political
climate and do you see any positive way
out of this and into a more normal
political climate
yeah you know I think it's it's I hate
to say this it's complicated you know
this seems to be the theme of uh this
month's AMA this is a real issue there's
a real question this is not like oh
there's some simple answer that has been
overlooked part of it is at the level of
Politics As we discussed with people
like will Wilkinson and Ezra Klein there
is more polarization politicians have
done the game theory calculation that if
what they want to maximize is their
chance of getting reelected rather than
what is best for the country then
stoking dislike of the other political
party is the way to go it makes it
harder to compromise and get things done
but if you don't care about compromising
and getting things done all you care
about is getting out your vote then
that's the way to go and this has been
creeping up on us for a while but at
least since the 90s it's become very
Vivid and very obvious but there's other
things going on I know I do think that
modernity the modern world modern uh
technological industrial society
gives people the impression that they
are left behind and they feel bad about
it there's a lot of people out there who
feel powerless who do not feel that the
Democratic institutions are on their
side who do not feel supported that
don't have either jobs at all or don't
have good jobs you know they have jobs
that are not very meaningful not very
high paying not very secure Etc we don't
have good health care and things like
that in the United States anyway and
this builds up resentment it builds up
dislike of the system and people don't
always react rationally to that feeling
of uh feeling powerless and so they're
more likely to overthrow the
institutions or not to respect the
institutions that they have and then
other people take advantage of that
right they inflame those sentiments and
use them to get power you know it goes
back to
the podcast needed long ago with Edward
Watts about the uh end of the Roman
Republic where the groki brothers who
with the best of intentions maybe they
wanted to be populists and they wanted
to share the land and distribute it from
you know a small number of very rich
people to a larger number of citizens
but the way that they did it was to
assemble a mob and to pressure the
Senate to go along with them and then
once you open that Pandora's Box and you
realize oh the way to get my political
goals
reached is not to pass a bill but to
assemble a mob
that becomes a way of operating right
that becomes something you can do and uh
maybe we're getting there in the United
States right now do I see a positive way
out of this
um
I'm honestly not sure again I don't mean
to weasel out of this
to me this is absolutely uncertainty I
think that we could very well get out of
this you know we could sort of calm down
and go back to a world where there's
political disagreement but it's not
always end of the world level stuff but
we might not you know the United States
uh here in the United States which is
where I'm thinking about is what the
question is about but there's similar
things you could say about other
countries
um our constitutional system has lasted
a long time historically speaking over
two centuries there's no guarantee it
lasts another two centuries it might not
last another 10 years
who knows you know we're going to have
another election in 2024 I could easily
see people just go online people have
laid out the failure modes if there's an
election in which one candidate I'll
pretend not to know which candidate it
would be or for which political party
would be but you can all fill in the
blanks
if one candidate wins most of the state
elections and therefore wins the
electoral college but the other
candidate has supporters that are on the
state legislatures or are the Secretary
of State in the states where they lost
and those States choose to not respect
the will of their voters and to hand in
a list of electors that is different
than what people actually voted for you
could absolutely overthrow the actual
Democratic decision of our system and
guess what people would not like that
people would object to that and who
knows what happens next it is not at all
difficult to see a future where
democracy in the U.S comes crashing down
uh in a very short time scale I'm not
going to assign a probability to it
because I really truly don't know but it
is conceivable and plausible in a way
that 10 or 20 years ago it just wasn't
and so that's a scary thought
Anders Hector says is it possible to
calculate the contribution to entropy of
a human life and how a welder or a
cleaner fair in comparison to for
example Albert Einstein or an ant or a
tree who contribute more to reducing who
contributes more to reducing entropy and
what can I do to reduce the liability
side of my net footprint on entropy you
know I would not worry about reducing
the liability side of your net entropy
input there's many many things in the
universe that are making way more
entropy than you are like the sun the
sun you know radiating out into space
does enormously more to increase the
entropy of the universe than every human
being who ever existed in total
um you know human beings are mostly
themselves at a more or less constant
entropy it's not that we ourselves
increase in entropy is that we increase
the entropy of the world around us by
you know eating
and sweating and making noise and making
podcasts and all this stuff all these
irreversible processes increase the
entropy of the universe and so uh
I don't think there's a huge difference
I don't know how to calculate the
difference between Albert Einstein and
an ant I don't Einstein is bigger you
know he ate more food so he probably
creates more entropy but again it's
nothing compared to very natural
processes out there in the universe so I
just wouldn't worry about it
Paul Duffield says when are Infinities
bugs and when are they features
sometimes physicists treat them as an
indicator that the maths behind a theory
no longer applies to reality in some way
and sometimes they're treated as a
possible outcome is there a consistent
difference here are these different
types of infinity or is it more of a
case-by-case thing
I think it's largely a case-by-case
thing but there's a rough kind of guide
when you're talking about the sort of
setup you know the physical space of
possibilities or hilbrid space or phase
space or the size of the universe you
know the whole arena in which things
play out there's no principled reason
for that kind of thing not to be
infinite we have no evidence that that's
finite or conceptual evidence that it
should be finite Etc maybe it's infinite
the kinds of Infinities we tend to worry
about are when a quantity within the
universe that is usually finite is
predicted to become infinite because of
some prediction of an equation right
like the infinite curvature at a
singularity in general relativity or the
Infinity of uh renormalized Feynman
diagram or unreormalized vitamin diagram
we don't have experience within nature
within our experience of seeing infinite
things in any ways so it's those kinds
of Infinities within the physical
universe that we worry about as
predictions of our theories but the
universe itself being infinite is not
something that we treat as a big problem
okay the last question comes from Cooper
who says I'm going to be a father next
year and it has had me thinking about my
moral responsibility to my children
compared to my community and Country
we're moving to a nicer house in a
better school district which I'm very
aware is a privilege than many other
children in this country don't have
how do you think about your moral
responsibility to those Close to You
compared to the broader world I don't
want to further contribute to inequality
but at the same time I want to give my
children the best life I have the power
to give
you know I put this question last
because it's a Whopper it's another
super duper complicated important
question again going back to the very
beginning of the podcast I I value these
conversations you know I I don't just do
the amas out of a sense of obligation
although there is that but I actually
really do get something out of some of
the good questions that are being asked
here um
this is one of the reasons why I'm not a
pure utilitarian consequentialist I'll
uh Peter Singer because I think it's
okay to care to put more effort into
caring about your children than to
caring about people elsewhere in the
world or in other times that you don't
know and have never met okay uh I think
that there it is Perfectly Natural again
I'm a moral constructivist so people are
going to invent construct their versions
of morality based on their inclinations
and their inclinations are to pay more
attention to people close to them than
to people far away I think that's okay I
don't you know I remember when we had
the moving naturalism forward uh get
together
Stephen Weinberg wanted to talk about
morality that was that was his request
he didn't want to talk about physics and
of course everyone's like yeah you just
talk about whatever you want but he gave
a very unconvincing talk about morality
because he said yeah I don't I think
morality is overrated and the example he
gave was that he will make an effort to
recruit a hot young physicist to the
University of Texas where he was because
he wants the University of Texas to do
well even if the larger community of
physicists does not necessarily benefit
from that and the rest of us are like
you know that's not immoral that's just
pointing out that your version of
morality you know puts some extra
emphasis on your local uh environment
and then that's okay that is a version
to morality it might not be everyone's
Peter Sanger wants to convince you to
care about everyone equally
I think it's almost inhumanly difficult
to actually do that I don't think you
should not care about other people so
that's the balance that comes in and you
know whether or not we are thinking
about sending our children to school or
whether or not we're thinking about
regulating free speech on Twitter or
whether we're thinking about talking
about gender and sexuality it's okay to
admit there are different considerations
that need to be balanced rather than
saying oh here's the simple clear once
and for all answer
there's a problem of inequality in the
United States in the world I think we
should make an effort to make the world
better for people who are not having a
good time for people who are the Lesser
off people in the world I think it's
also okay to play by the rules right
whatever the rules are if you're not
actively hurting other people to try to
make the world better for your children
is fine try to make their environment
better is fine also try to make the
world better for other people's children
you can do those at the same time
um this is where you know effective
altruism sort of gets into trouble there
are people who take it so seriously that
they become miserable they think like
the only good thing that I can do in the
world is to give away everything I own
because I'm going to save some lives
somewhere else and then they become
miserable and it's not a good long-term
strategy
I think you should care about everybody
and it's okay to care about people who
are near to you more the exact balance
is really really difficult to strike and
honestly probably we err on the side of
caring about people near to us too much
and people far away not enough that I
would absolutely buy
um but that's that's complicated it's
difficult to exactly balance that I
certainly wouldn't feel guilty about
doing what is best for your own children
okay I do think that we can also do more
to change the world to get rid of
inequality Etc but don't make that feel
guilty like that's that's a trap I don't
I think that that's wrong there's no it
shouldn't be thought of as a competition
between you and other people and uh the
rest of the world like there's a there's
a zero-sum game between what you do for
your children or your family and what
you do for the rest of the world it's
not a zero-sum game we can can all work
to make everyone better off and you know
we can probably most of us including
myself can do more to help the rest of
the world
um that would be that's a much better
argument if someone wants to argue that
I'm not doing enough to help the rest of
the world
I might have to I might have to agree
with that but I would not agree that I I
am doing too much to help the people
near and dear to me I think that's okay
we can do both
should try to do both
as well as we can that's who we are as
human beings and with that
have a good rest of the Year have a good
rest of 2022 I will of course we have a
couple more podcasts before the end of
the year but the next AMA will be end of
January so have good holidays and things
like that thanks again for the support
of mindscape means a lot to me take care
and talk to you later
[Music]
mama
[Music]